bonjour à toutes et à tous mes chers
collègues nous recevons ce matin au
titre de leur mission de coordinateur de
la mission exigences des savoirs
monsieur Édouard Geffry directeur
général de l'enseignement scolaire
madame Caroline Pascal chef de
l'Inspection générale de l'éducation du
sport et de la Recherche monsieur
tanislas Deen président du conseil
scientifique et de l'éducation nationale
et Monsieur Gilles Albou recteur de
l'académie d'orléant tour et je les
remercie de s'être rendu disponible pour
cette change qu'il me semblait
indispensable d'avoir en effet la
mission exigence des savoirs a vu le
jour au début du mois d'octobre 2023 à
l'initiative d'une ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
cette mission a pris la forme d'un d'une
large concertation dans l'objectif
d'identifier les principales mesures à
prendre pour reéhausser le niveau
scolaire des élèves de la maternelle au
lycée et de proposer un plan
opérationnel de mise en œuvre quatre
grandes thématiques ont été définies
dans le cadre de vos travaux les
programmes les pratiques pédagogiques
l'organisation pédagogique la culture
générale et les disciplines
complémentaires des savoirs
fondamentaux la question du niveau des
savoirs est évidemment un sujet central
dont nous avons encore pu récemment
mesurer toute l'importance avec les
résultats préoccupants de l'étude de
l'enquête PISA montrant une baisse sans
précédent du niveau des élèves cette
baisse cette baisse touche l'ensemble
des pays de l'OCDE et s'explique au
moins partiellement par l'impact de la
pandémie de covid-19 sur l'enseignement
et la France se situe dans la moyenne
des pays de l'OCDE avec quelques
spécificités qui doivent retenir toute
notre attention notamment le fait que
nous sommes l'un des pays où les
inégalités sociales pèsent le plus sur
les résultats scolaires les conclusions
de votre mission ont nourri le travail
qui a abouti au plan annoncé par le
ministre Gabriel Atal pour un choc des
savoirs ce plan comporte 20 mesures
fortes qui entreront pour certaines
d'entre elles en vigueur dès la rentrée
elle vise à mieux soutenir les
professeurs adapter l'organisation des
les enseignements aux besoins des élèves
et réhausser le niveau d'exigence et
d'ambition global je retiens en
particulier l'annonce de la création de
groupes de niveau en 6e et 5e pour les
mathématiques et le français en en
limitant à une quinzaine d'élèves les
groupes les plus en difficulté le
renforcement des stages de réussite le
dernier mot donné au professeurs
concernant le redoublement et les
dispositions visant à créer un sursaut
en mathématique notamment avec une
nouvelle épreuve anticipée en première
générale et technologique donc madamees
messieurs pourriez-vous nous rappeler la
manière dont vous avez conduit vos
travaux les échanges et les
consultations que vous avez mené les
annonces du ministre reprennent-elles
l'intégralité de vos recommandations ou
bien certaines ont-elles été écartées ou
ajoutées quel sujet vous paraissent
prioritaire et sans plus attendre je
vais vous céder la parole pour une
première intervention liminaire de 5
minutes environ chacun et puis ensuite
nous aurons les orateurs de groupe donc
je vais vous donner la parole dans
l'ordre de présentation qui est l'ordre
où vous êtes sur à la
tribune voilà don il fallait bien
choisir monsieurir Geffry merci beaucoup
Mad présidente madames et Messieurs les
Députés alors rapidement donc en terme
de de paysage vous avez commencé à
adresser le le constat qui a d'ailleurs
été conforté par PISA euh qui est un
constat que je dirais ambivalent
c'est-à-dire un redressement Progressiv
sur le premier degré observé depuis euh
maintenant 6 ans euh y compris par les
enquête internationale PES et cetera
donc qui montre un mouvement sur le 1ier
degré et en revanche des résultats plus
que préoccupants sur le second degré
avec une très forte baisse du niveau
plus forte que celle de nos partenaires
de l'OCDE euh caractérisé notamment par
dans dans la ST de PISA par une
augmentation du nombre d'élèves en
difficulté qui passe entre 2012 et 2022
de
22,4 % à 29 % et en vis-à-vis une très
forte baisse quasiment de 50 % des
élèves très à l'aise qui passent de 13 à
7 %. euh ce constat là il est il a été
donc dressé par le CDE il a en fait
conforter malheureusement euh évidemment
des éléments que nous avions déjà
notamment par les tests de
positionnement en seconde et qui montrre
qu'il y a aujourd'hui euh j'allais dire
enfin que que la période du collège est
une période qui se traduit en fait par
une cristallisation de la difficulté
scolaire voire parfois par une
aggravation euh euh de cette difficulté
scolaire et donc c'est c'est dans ce ce
cet environnement là que le ministre a
donc lancé cette cette mission mission
vous l'avez rappelé qui se traduit
notamment par une enquête pour la
première fois auprès de tous les
personnels pédagogiques du ministère
enquête à laquelle 230000 collègues ont
répondu et qui a montré d'ailleurs des
des résultats tout à fait intéressants
alors il il y a plusieurs axes sur
lesquels on va on va revenir les uns et
les autres il y a évidemment un axe
pédagogique autour des programmes qui
sera dév par Caroline
Pascal l'axe autour des pratiques
pédagogiques qui est notamment de
l'enjeu des manuels et des méthodes
pédagogiques par Stanislas Dean et puis
la question du redressement spécifique
en mathématique euh euh qui sera traité
par Gill Albou en ce qui me concerne et
si vous voulez bien je vis simplement
vous dire en quelques en 3
minutes le le fruit des travaux et et et
donc don le dont le ministre at tire un
N de conclusion sur la personnalisation
des parcours le constat aujourd'hui
c'est que euh il y a en fait un très
grand il y a eu depuis une trentaine
d'années maintenant un processus qui a
abouti à un très grand lissage des
parcours autrement dit que l'élève soit
en difficulté ou pas voir en très grande
difficulté statistiquement aujourd'hui
il est si je peux dire pris dans un dans
un dans un dans un dans un dans une dans
une scolarité complètement Liss qui se
traduit de fait par la quasi disparition
du redoublement en moins de 10 ans et
qui se traduit aussi par une très faible
personnalisation du parcours notamment
au collège avec un effet qui est connu
et documenté hein scientifiquement qui
est malheureusement que euh la très
grande difficulté scolaire au CP est
tristement prédictive de la très grande
difficulté scolaire au DNB et après
autrement dit s'il à la fin du CP un
enfant aujourd'hui par exemple a des
très grandes difficultés en décodage
compte tenu de ce qui'est l'organisation
scolaire les les les pratiques et cetera
et cetera la probabilité qu'il soit en
très très grande difficulté 10 ans plus
tard au au au moment de passer diation
du brevet est extrêmement élevé et c'est
cette fatalité là qu'il faut
évidemment casser parce que ce n'est pas
une fatalité c'est un constat mais
justement l'enjeu c'est de le c'est de
le combattre et donc il y a eu un C
nombre de mesures qui ont été annoncées
je me permets simplement si voulez bien
de d'en reprendre la substance d'abord
autour de la personnalisation des
parcours avec cette idée notamment que
en primaire notamment l'école
élémentaire il vaut sans doute mieux
réussir en 6 ans que
se retrouver en grande difficulté en 5
et avec un système qui n'est pas du tout
une massification du redoublement mais
qui consiste par cercle concentrique à
rendre possible la personalisation des
parcours d'abord en conditionnant le
passage au niveau supérieur à certains
dispositifs de remédiation type stage de
réussite pend les vacances et ce donc on
sait qu'ils ont un effet extrêmement
bénéfique ça c'est
mesurable et puis le cas échéant si
l'ensemble des dispositifs de
remédiation nont pas n'ont pas réussi à
pouvoir plus facilement qu'aujourd'hui
redoublé puisque comme je le disais
aujourd'hui le le redoublement esté est
tout à fait exceptionnel de moins de
moins de 1 % he grosso modo par an et
donc l'idée c'est que sans revenir du
tout à des niveaux qu'on connaissait
dans les an 80 qui étaaiit de lè unanime
excessif puisqu'on était à 30 % de
génération qui était en situation de de
de retard entre guillemets en CM2 en
tout cas qu'on puisse donner les moyens
à l'élève de consolider les acquis à des
moment charnière notamment en CP par
exemple où euh euh on sait que si il il
il perdure avec unee difficulté il sera
en fait on le on le condamne ensuite à à
une à une très très forte difficulté ou
à des efforts qui seront considérable
alors même qu'il suffit de lisser son
parcours cette fois-ci non pas au sens
le rendre parfaitement identique à celui
de tous les autres mais au sens assurer
une progressivité de ces apprentissages
beaucoup plus forte qu'aujourd'hui le
deuxième aspect c'est évidemment et donc
cette question du redoublement elle se
pose essentiellement elle peut se poser
plus tard mais elle se pose
essentiellement à l'école de primaire et
scientifiquement d'ailleurs démontré que
c'est là qu'elle a le plus gros effet
pour les élèves à condition de pas être
repris à identique mais d'être
personnalisé au collège se pose la
question effectivement des groupes de
niveaux enfin c'est pas une question
c'est une question qui a été posée et
que le ministre a tranché désormais
alors trois points importants là-dessus
il ne s'agit pas de faire des classes de
niveau donc on n pas la classe des bons
et la classe des des élèves avec un
niveau intermédiaire et puis la classe
des élèves qui sera en difficulté par ça
on sait que ça marche pas on a des
classes qui sont parfaitement mixte en
terme de niveau scolaire mais en
français et en mathématiqu pour ces deux
disciplines là il y aura des groupes de
niveau dès la rentrée scolaire 24 en 6e
et en 5e pour permettre tout simplement
à chacun d'apprendre dans les meilleures
conditions et apprendre dans les
meilleures conditions ça veut dire
permettre aux élèves les plus en
difficulté d'être notamment en groupe à
effectif réduit le ministre a évoqué des
groupes d'une quinzaine d'élèves pour C
pour pour les élèves qui connaissent des
difficultés difficultés qui sont là
aussi parfaitement documenté puisque les
évaluation de 6e que nous menons de
plusieurs années montrent que
statistiquement on a entre 25 et 30 %
des élèves qui sont en maîtrise
insuffisante ou très insuffisante en
France et en mathématiqu et donc pour
ces élèves là et bien il y aura la
possibilité d'avoir des groupes donc à
effectif réduit pour leur permettre
d'avancer mieux et plus vite et ces
groupes deuxième élément important parce
que c'est aussi documenté
scientifiquement seront évidemment
révisables par période c'est qu'on
pourra passer d'un groupe à l'autre avec
uneé une meilleure confiance en soi et
des résultats qui seront très
probablement également meilleurs et puis
le trisème éément je m'arrête là-dessus
c'est la fin du collège avec le diplôme
national du brevet pour redonner sa
valeur à ce diplôme vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui ce diplôme que que vous
l'ayez ou pas il n'y a pas de
conséquence il y en aura désormais
puisque il est censé sanctionner la
maîtrise du socle et donc si vous ne
maîtrisez pas le socle et bien vous ne
pourrez pas passer en secondes et c'est
pour ça donc que le ministre a souhaité
que nous mettions en place ce qu'on
appelle des prépas secondes c'est-à-dire
la possibilité pour un élève qui n'a pas
enfin l'obligation pour un élève qui n'a
pas le
DNB de passer par une classe entre
guillemets de préparatoire au lycée pour
lui permettre simplement de consolider
des acquis qui n'auraient pas été et
puis de mieux préparer la poursuite de
ces études l'objectif estant Infiné que
chacun réussisse mieux voilà pour la
partie on va dire organisationnelle en
résumé et puis évidemment le cœur du
réacteur qui est pédagogique et je
laisse la parole à Caroline Pascal bien
bonjour à tous quelques mots en effet
sur les programmes donc la notre notre
mission c'est c'est appuyer à la fois
sur les travaux des trois groupes de
travail he qui école collège et lycée
sur le dans lesqueles la question des
programmes a été très largement évoquée
et elle est aussi très reprise à avec de
manière assez unanime par les
professeurs dans le questionnaire dont
vous avez pu voir dans le dossier de
presse que 230000 professeurs avaient
répondu hein ce qui est quand même une
un échantillon très représentatif de ce
qu'il pense sur les programmes notre
objectif et et la la la ligne que nous
avons suivie c'est celle de parvenir à
mieux savoir ce qu'on enseigne pour bien
l'enseigner ça supposait finalement
trois objectifs clarifier nos programmes
je vais y revenir euh les rendre plus
lisibles et plus progressifs et
promouvoir des méthodes appuyées sur la
science et sur les bonnes pratique pour
euh cette révision des programmes que
nous avons envisagé je reviendrai un
instant sur le sur le calendrier euh
nous sommes appuyé en partie sur ce que
disaient les enseignants qui à 70 %
disent que c'est quand même leur
référence de départ au moment où ils
construisent euh leur enseignement euh
et que ils considèrent en revanche
qu'ils sont difficilement lisibles et et
d'une part à 27 % et qu'ils sont pas
toujours ni adaptés au niveau des élèves
et à leurs besoins ni adaptés au temps
d'enseignement le premier point
c'est-à-dire adapté à leurs besoins est
un point très important puisque la
question enfin les dans les annonces du
ministre C cette proposition a été
reprise que les programmes soient écrits
non plus par rapport à ce que les
professeurs doivent faire mais par
rapport à ce que les élèves doivent
avoir donc se concentrer sur les acquis
que les élèves doivent avoir la deuxième
question qui s'était posée c'est celle
des repères annuels ou des repères de
cyclle la constitution des des cycles de
3 ans conduisait à ça qu'un certain
nombre d'acquis des élèves soit reporté
d'année en année jusqu'à la fin du cycle
la la réécriture de programme nous
conduira comme ça l'avait déjà été
depuis
2017-28 à réintroduire des repère annuel
pour l'ensemble des programmes qu'il
s'agisse des programmes d'école ou des
programmes de collège de manière à ce
que chaque enseignant sache ce que les
élèves devront avoir acquis à la fin de
l'année sans reporter nécessairement sur
la suite de son de son
parcours ce sont les points essentiels
autre point qu'il que nous avons
également souligné c'est la nécessité
non pas de rendre moins exigeant les
programmes au contraire hein cette
mission avait vocation à relever
l'exigence des acquis des élèves mais à
les clarifier et à les rendre moins
lourd euh à force de réécriture
puisque000 depuis 2008 les programmes ne
cessent d'être réécrits euh l'absence de
priorités devenait de plus en plus nette
c'est-à-dire à force de les réécrire
dans le fond on rajoutait des éléments
donc la question est aujourd'hui de les
relarifier de noter précisément et
d'indiquer précisément aux enseignant
quelles sont les priorités des acquis
des élèves à l'issue de l'année dont ils
ont la charge de les recentrer sur ces
priorités avec des repères annuels et ce
que nous avons appelé la clause de
revoyure de fin de cycle c'estàd que
nous n'avons pas Suppr nous n'avons pas
proposé de supprimer les cycles nous
avons proposé que ce cycle de 3 ans
permette à ceux qui ont besoin d'un peu
plus de temps pour acquérir certaines
notions puissent y revenir mais sous
condition qu'elles ai déjà été vues au
moment où elles sont inscrites dans le
dans le programme ce qui est une une
approche un peu différente de de la
notion de cycle que celle qui existait
jusqu'ici tout ceci sera accompagné de
test de positionnement proposé par la
DEP he au ministère et qui devrait
permettre aux enseignants de s'assurer
des acquis des élèves au fur et à mesure
de leur de leur enseignement et appuyer
sur des méthodes éprouvées je je
laisserai mon mon collègue Gilles
revenir sur notamment sur les
mathématiques
le calendrier prévu pour cette révision
des des des des programmes nous conduit
à travailler essentiellement sur l'école
cette année pour la rentrée 24 jusqu'en
CE2 pour la rentrée 25 CM1 6e et puis
ensuite une révision des programmes de
collège même si le message qui a été
très largement diffusé entendu est celui
de français mat cette question des
repères annuels se posera pour
l'ensemble des programmes et donc
l'ensemble des programmes seront revu
dans la l'esprit et la philosophie que
je viens de de présenter permettez-moi
simplement deux mots maintenant sur le
socle et sur la culture générale puisque
là j'ai parlé des programmes
disciplinaires hein euh la question du
socle s'est aussi posée les enseignants
disent en très grande majorité qu'ils ne
savent pas très bien s'en servir et
qu'ils ne sont pas très euh
euh d'ailleurs il ils s'en servent peu
et ils le connaissent mal en quelque
sorte euh donc nous avons proposé que ce
socle continue d'exister que ce soit ce
que tout élève doit savoir en sortant de
l'école obligatoire mais qu'il se cont
concentre sur des choses là encore
lisibles et compréhensibles pour les
enseignants c'est-à-dire les compétences
disciplinaires avant tout compétences
disciplinaires au service euh des
fondamentaux français et mathématiques
en quoi l'ensemble des compétences
disciplinaires constru dans chaque
discipline servent la maîtrise du
français et des mathématiques les
compétences psychosociales c'est-à-dire
l'assurance la confiance en soi la
capacité à se projeter la méthode euh la
capacité à travailler seul et cetera le
travail en équipe aussi l'organisation
de son travail donc t tous ces éléments
qui doivent ensuite permettre aux élèves
de réussir au lycée puis de réussir à
l'enseignement supérieur et enfin des
connaissances de culture générale avec
des repère identifiés pour construire
une culture commune à tous les élèves
qui sortiront de l'école obligatoire de
la scolarité obligatoire c'est un point
qui a été très largement
discuté personne ni dans les audition
que nous avons mené ni dans les groupes
des travails ni entre nous quatre n'ont
envisagé ou n'ont retenu l'idée d'une
discipline culture générale mais au
contraire repérer dans chacun des
programmes disciplinaires les
connaissances qui fondent pour nous une
une culture commune que tous les élèves
sortants de l'école française doivent
partager ce ces repères seront donc
identifiés dans les programmes
disciplinaires et constitueront dans le
socle la culture générale pour terminer
euh cette ce calendrier là est plutôt
autour de la rentrée 25 d'abord parce
que le travail sur les programmes doit
commencer avant d'identifier les
objectifs qui seront ceux du socle et
permettront une entrée en vigueur en
même temps que les programmes de de de
collège jusqu'au
collège c'est c'est un enjeu le ministre
l'a répété hein c'est un enjeu très
important majeur je devrais dire
d'égalité des chances cette cette
culture qui doit être à la fois une
culture humaniste et qui tiendra compte
évidemment des repères dans l'ensemble
des disciplines de lettre et sciences
humaines mais aussi une culture
scientifique avec de véritables repères
et des et des des des réflexions fortes
sur la vérité la preuve et cetera tout
tout ça pour évidemment éviter la la la
la la force des réseaux sociaux et des
fake news et enfin ajouter à tout cela
une forme de conscience d'une destinée
partagée qui est celle du pays ce sont
donc des repères importants pour nous et
ça a donné lieu à une proposition assez
forte je ne reviens pas ensuite sur des
programmes plus spécifiques que nous
avons pointé par exemple celui des
langues vivantes hein de manière à
éviter que tous les élèves fassent tous
les ans et dans toutes les langues la
même chose et qu'on retrouve bien là
encore un ancrage culturel propre à
chaque pays voilà je crois que et je
laisse la parole à à stanisas Dean qui
va ou à Gill sur les mathématique comme
vous le souhaitez puison é sur il faut
que voilà bonjour à à toutes et tous et
et puisqu'on est sur les les programmes
effectivement on peut enchaîner Caroline
venait de le
dire donc on a on a beaucoup travaillé
sur la la la culture générale et la
partager évidemment ça nous amène à à
évoquer la culture la culture
scientifique et donc les mathématiques
et et et l'informatique et évidemment
notre notre ambition c'est aussi de
développer chez tous les élèves non
seulement comme le disait Caroline la
maîtrise de la langue mais aussi la
capacité d'argumenter de raisonner un
raisonnement appuyé sur des faits
scientifiques et aussi évidemment de des
développer l'esprit critique chez chez
les élèves euh on est un un pays une
nation qui peut s'en orgueillir d'avoir
un grand nombre de de reconnaissance de
médaill fields et en même temps on voit
ces dernières années
séodé la confiance des jeunes en la en
les sciences et de des jeunes qui
remettent de plus en plus en question
des des vérités scientifiques euh et en
parallèle les si on regarde aussi les
les les études PISA on voit et c'est un
un sujet qui nous a beaucoup préoccupé
que les écarts de résultats entre les
filles et les garçons
euh plus de plus de 10 points euh mais
c'est pas propre à la France hein et
c'est c'est c'est général depuis depuis
20 ans ne se sont absolument pas euh
résorbés euh et puis euh dernier point
et dernier dernier constat au moment où
euh le le président de la République et
le gouvernement ont fait de la
souveraineté économique et industrielle
un enjeu majeur une priorité euh pour
pour la France on peut pas aujourd'hui
penser un
développement économique et notamment un
développement industriel avec des élèves
qui ont des grandes lacunes en
mathématiqu parce que comme le rappelait
Édouard si les résultats sont très
mauvais ils sont particulièrement
mauvais en mathématique ou on a du
décrochage alors dans les évidemment
dans les les les les mesures
que sur lesquelles nous avons réfléchi
comme on peut reprendre évidemment
toutes les toutes les mesures qui ont
été évoquées par Édouard et et et
Caroline je voudrais commencer aussi par
rappeler ce qui a été fait et notamment
le le le plan villanitorocian qui avait
fait qui avait posé une une analyse et
déjà des des pistes et notamment à
travers les les 21 mesures qui ont été
déployées dans dans ce plan
euh je voudrais rappeler tout ce que
nous devons faire et ce que nous avons
commencé à faire pour entre guillemets
réconcilier les élèves avec les
mathématiques on y reviendra d'ailleurs
sur sur le contenu sur les programmes ça
passe évidemment par les par les clubs
par aussi le développement de la la
culture scientifique dans les auditions
on a eu des beaux témoignages
d'opération notamment
avec des scientifiques côté la main à la
patte on peut parler aussi de de mat en
jein et toutes ces opérations qui
maintenant peuvent être financé dans le
cadre du passculture puisque le
passculture s'ouvre à la culture
scientifique euh c'est aussi
développer
la le le le le travail en commun et en
partenariat avec avec les chercheurs
notamment dans la formation continue des
enseignants à travers les labos euh les
Labau de de mathématiques les labomat
qui eux aussi peuvent être financés dans
le cadre du CNR du Conseil national de
la refondation avec de très très belles
expérimentations qui ont été mis en
place avec là aussi des des beaux
travaux euh qui sont déployés dans dans
les établissements c'est Caroline le
disait évidemment un travail sur le
contenu et là en mathématique comme
ailleurs on vient de loin donc on a
beaucoup parlé le ministre sera beaucoup
parlé de de la méthode de Singapour et
peut-être que Stanislas reviendra mais
enfin la méthode de Singapour de
Singapour elle est elle-même euh issue
des travaux de recherche français euh et
notamment didacticien français elle a
été évidemment choisi euh euh par euh
euh par Singapour parce queelle avait
fait ses preuves malheureusement en
France on on on a des bons chercheurs en
didactique et parfois on oublie de de de
l'appliquer euh donc là là aussi avec un
retour aux enseignements explicites un
retour sur la
manipulation et on le sait dès le plus
jeune âge et notamment dès dès la
maternelle je je je rappelle ici
évidemment les les différentes étapes
verbaliser après avoir manipulé et
ensuite abstraire alors que pendant
longtemps dans le système français on a
commencé par abstraire et puis ensuite à
appliquer c'est aussi le Tr travaille
par amener les les les élèves à à
appréhender les mathématiques par la
résolution de problème et quand on voit
les résultats justement sur les les
évaluations que ce soit les les
évaluations nationales ou les
évaluations PISA on voit que c'est un
domaine sur lequel nos élèves pêchent le
plus et puis c'est aussi réintroduire de
manière plus précoce un certain nombre
de notions parce qu'on sait que
et reviendra là-dessus que notamment sur
les nomes fractions et les décimaux les
intr produire en CM1 c'est trop trop
tard et et donc dans la réflexion qu'il
y aura sur sur les programmes il y
a aussi c ces apprentissages qui doit se
faire de manière plus précoce et puis
évidemment toutes les mesures qui ont
été mise en avant notamment les manuels
parce que comme on on le voit souvent
quand il manque des manuels c'est
souvent les manuels de mathématiques
donc là aussi une réflexion à avoir sur
sur les manuels et notamment en CP en
CE1 et évidemment sur les groupes de
niveau parce que c'est là aussi que le
les les les les les écarts sont les plus
criants et les mathématique étant
cumulative si on
a loupé si on a raté
l'acquisition de
de de notion de base on ne pourra pas
progresser euh et puis évidemment c'est
pour nous l'épreuve anticipée de de de
première VO pour pour rappelle
aujourd'hui le bac c'est trois épreuves
terminales communes et toutes les trois
autour des humanités le français écrit
le français oral et la philosophie et
donc évidemment on ne pouvait que
regretter l'absence de d'une
certification sur les mathématiques et
et plus largement sur les sciences pour
évidemment redonner une une cible
commune et une cible euh qui euh qui qui
doit être collective pour tester
notamment la capacité à appréhander les
ple les principaux objets mathématiqu
indispensable à tous euh on a
réintroduit les mathématiques pour tous
en première et il est important que on
puisse tester cette capacité à
appréhender les outils communs mais
aussi la capacité à résoudre des
problèmes fondés sur des données et
aussi bien j'ai commencé par par souci
tout à l'heure construire un
raisonnement logique donc on va
réfléchir et et travailler sur ce que
peuvent être ces épreuves communes alors
peut-être pas communes à l'ensemble des
élèves il y aura peut-être des épreuves
différentes suivant que les élèves
auront pris ou n'auront pas pris
l'enseignement de spécialité mathématiqu
mais évidemment la cible c'est qu'il y
ait un niveau de certification pour tous
les
élèves d'enseignements généraux et
technologiques merci mes chers collègues
je vous rappelle que nous avons une
salle très sonore et que tous vos
appartés si vous pouvez les faire avec
un tout petit peu moins de enfin baisser
un petit peu le le ton parce que on a
enfin moi j'ai même des fois du mal à
entendre les orateurs de de là où je
suis monsieur Stanistlas Deen c'est à
vous oui merci
bonjour un dernier mot donc moi j'ai
participé à cette mission au titre de
président du conseil scientifique de
l'éducation nationale et en tentant le
plus possible d'apporter la lumière pas
seulement de ce que je connais mais de
de mes collègues du conseil scientifique
vous savez que c'est 29 scientifiques
bénévoles qui essayent d'éclairer les
décisions bon le temps été très court on
était parfois préparé sur certain sujet
moins préparé sur d'autres je le dis
franchement donc la la réflexion et la
consultation continue avec le Conseil
Scientifique évidemment c'était une des
demandes fortes du conseil scientifique
que la culture scientifique et
mathématique fasse partie intégrante des
décisions et c'est le cas et ça a été ça
a été dit à l'instant j'interviens pour
préciser les choses sur un autre sujet
qui est très important qui est celui des
manuels et des méthodes pour
l'enseignement puisque ça fait partie
des grandes décisions du ministre et
c'était notre suggestion vous savez que
en primaire il y a un tiers des
enseignants qui n'ont pas de manuel et
ce n'est pas forcément leur décision
souvent c'est simplement parce que le
manuel est dépassé n'est pas
disponible ça peut être dans les cas des
enseignants expérimenté une décision
volontaire mais les enquêtes ont montré
que souvent ça conduisait à
l'utilisation de méthodes qui ne sont
pas les plus efficaces ni pour la
lecture ni pour les mathématiques et on
a publié des notes d'alerte du conseil
scientifique là-dessus notamment sur la
lecture donc la recommandation était
double et elle est suivie la première
c'est d'avoir un manuel pour tous les
enseignants donc tous les enseignants de
primaire doivent avoir un manuel et s'en
servir et deuxièmement que ces manuels
puissent être labéisés c'est-à-dire
qu'il y ait des critères les plus
objectifs possibles qui conduisent à
améliorer l'efficacité de ces manuels
tout en respectant la diversité qui est
possible dans les méthodes pédagogiques
mais avec un respect de ce qui est connu
comme étant le plus efficace pour
enseigner par exemple la lecture au CP
donc ça viendra évidemment en lien très
étroit et je dirais dans un sorte de
cycle vertueux avec les programmes qui
vont spécifier beaucoup plus précisément
peut-être même à une échelle plus fine
que celle de l'année ce qui doit être
fait et puis les évaluations nationales
qui seront disponibles pour les
enseignants à tout moment qui
permettront dans des petites testes de
vérifier ce que savent réellement les
élèves donc l'idée c'est que là il y a
un écosystème complet qui comprend les
manuels et des manuels qui seront donc
labelllisés c'est une procédure qui
reste à définir mais qui devrait
impliquer à la fois des enseignants des
experts de la didactique des chercheurs
de manière à avoir un regard le plus
lucide possible sur la qualité des
manuel et nous disposons d'enquêtes qui
montrent déjà la corrélation entre
l'utilisation de tel ou tel mannuel et
la réussite des élèves alors ça c'était
le sujet je dirais principal
euh sur lequel on m'a demandé
d'intervenir ce matin je voulais revenir
un tout petit peu sur le rôle du conseil
scientifique pour terminer nous avons
été amenés à introduire des principes au
début de ce document de la mission qui
me paraissent important qui nous ont
paru importants et j'attire l'attention
sur deux d'entre eux en particulier le
premier c'est de ne pas oublier la
motivation et le bien-être des élèves
parce que l'école française a une
difficulté dans ce domaine et le
renforcement de l'exigence ne doit pas
se faire au détriment de l'importance
essentielle de la motivation d'apprendre
pour les élèves et la deuxième le
deuxième point qui est tout aussi
important c'est la nécessité d'évaluer
les décisions et les pratiques dans le
temps long le Conseil Scientifique
d'éducation nationale considère que
c'est un point sur lequel on insiste pas
assez toutes ces décisions sont
difficiles toutes peuvent être
controversé doiv être adapté au contexte
français et donc on doit se donner la
possibilité de vérifier d'abord bien sûr
que ces décisions soient alignées avec
ce qu'on sait déjà sur le plan
scientifique mais aussi de vérifier que
dans le contexte où elles ont été
implémenté et la beauté dans les détails
ça fonctionne ou ça fonctionne moins
bien qu'on ne le pense il faut jamais
oublier que lorsqu'on change des
politiques publiques on peut aussi faire
du tort aux élèves alors le débat a
était particulièrement vif et j'attire
vot attention làdessus sur le
redoublement je pense que vous en êtes
conscient puisquil y a des articles dans
la presse également le conseil
scientifique est divisé
ou même je dirais assez opposé à cette
question du redoublement sur la base de
résultats scientifiques qui montre avec
des méthodes vous savez d'économies qui
sont extrêmement intéressantes on peut
regarder des des pays où il y a un seuil
pour redoubler qui est très précis et
donc il y a des élèves qui sont juste
au-dessus du seuil des élèves qui sont
juste en dessous du seuil et en
regardant l'effet de cette discontinuité
alors que le niveau des élèves lui est
continu on peut regarder les
conséquences du redoublement et les
conséquences sont malheureusement pour
les élèves qu' subissent pas forcément
positive du tout elles peuvent être
positives au court terme au mieux alors
que c'est très coûteux mais sur le long
terme elles sont souvent négatives et
notamment en terme d'abandon de d'échec
scolaire parce que évidemment les élèves
ont un an de plus et quand ils arrivent
un peu plus tard et bien ils ont plus de
chance d'abandonner l'école donc il y a
un risque sérieux du redoublement alors
notre document de la mission est assez
nuancé sur ce point mais peut-être pas
encore assez pour certains membres du
conseil scientifique il est très clair
que la priorité ça doit être d'aider les
élèves d'apporter le maximum de soutien
aux élèves quand ils en ont besoin
d'anticiper sur le fait qu'ils ont ils
risquent de ne pas passer par exemple
l'examen du brevet de leur apporter du
soutien pendant l'année de leur
réapporter du soutien pendant l'été et
le la mission détail he tous les
mécanismes qui sont possibles dans ce
domaine et le redoublement ne doit
vraiment être qu'en dernière extrémité
on a discuté beaucoup au conseil
scientifique on est rediscutera on aura
une séance plinière là-dessus le 23
janvier sur le fait qu'un système qui
n'a aucun redoublement n sans doute pas
bon non plus parce que évidemment il y a
une perte de motivation ou de travail
des élèves probablement mais néanmoins
pour un élève individuel le fait de
redoubler c'est quand même une sanction
et c'est probablement une difficulté
supplémentaire dans son parcours solaire
et je termine là-dessus il faut penser
aux élèves avec handicap c'est très
important il y en a beaucoup il y en a
plus qu'on le pense et pour les élèves
avec handicap il est
souvent recommandé de redoubler alors
que ces élèves pourraient passer sur le
plan intellectuel à la classe suivante
en bénéficiant de dispositifs adaptés
comme l'utilisation d'un clavier par
exemple pour les élèves qui sont
dyspraxiques donc il faut vraiment
penser avec une très grande attention à
la personne de chaque élève et envisager
le redoublement comme une dernière
extrémité c'est ce qui a été discuté
dans notre
groupe merci Monsieur Dean donc nous
allons passer maintenant aux orateurs de
groupe et nous commençons avec Fabrice
Levigoureux pour le groupe renaissance
pour 2
minutes merci Madame la
présidentead le micro le micro ouais
merci madame messieurs euh nous avons vu
depuis le milieu des années 80 il y a
donc 40 ans le niveau des élèves baissé
de manière très préoccupante en français
et en mathématiques donc dans ces
matières dites fondamental euh
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont à la source de
toutes les autres face à cela notre
majorité a souhaité dès 2017 mettre en
œuvre une mesure importante dans les
écoles relevant de l'éducation
prioritaire mais pas seulement
d'ailleurs dans ma inscription dans des
écoles qui ne relèvent pas mais qui
concentrent des élèves en difficulté ce
sont le les dédoublements des classes de
CP puis de CE1 puis de grandes sections
dans les récents résultats des études
nationales et internationales on
constate une stabilisation peut-être une
légère progression pour la première
génération des doublements ce sont des
résultats à prendre avec prudence parce
qu'ils ont été bien sûr télescopés par
les effets délétaires de la crise
sanitaire sur les apprentissages
toutefois pour les élèves un peu plus
âgés qui n'ont pas été concerné par cet
investissement important dans le premier
degré les résultats du classement PISA
ou encore ceux de la journée défense et
citoyenneté sont les résultats sont
alarmants plus d'un jeune sur C et
prouve de très grandes de très grandes
difficultés en lecture se fondant sur ce
constat le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a souhaité vous vous confier
cette tour de tâche de lui proposer des
pistes de solution pour renforcer le
niveau des élèves dans le cadre de la
mission exigence des savoirs je souhaite
ici au nom de mon groupe vous en
remercier vos conclusions permettent au
ministrees de présenter des mesures
fortes visant à élever le le niveau des
enfants et des adolescents à l'école au
collège au lycée dans le cadre de la
feuille de route choc des
savoirs je pense à la reconsidération à
la prise en compte du brevet des
collèges ou encore à la constitution non
pas de classe vous l'avez dit de niveau
mais de groupes de niveau au collège
pour les cours de français et
mathématiques avec des effectifs réduits
pour les groupes les plus en difficulté
nous sommes en effet convaincus que
l'adaptation organisationnelle constitue
un levier pensable à l'accroissement des
performances scolaires et à la réduction
des inégalités sociales j'imais aussi
que le ministre a retenu les
propositions relatives à l'apprentissage
de la lecture que nous formulons avec an
Genevard dans le cadre d'une mission sur
l'apprentissage de la lecture que cette
commission nous a confié je pense
notamment au financement par l'état de
manuel scolaire au progression éprouvé
par la science et par les pratiques
pédagogiques nous devons renforcer le
goût pour la lecture l'envie de lire la
motivation vous l'avez dit Monsieur Deen
pouvez-vous nous indiquer vos analyses
sur cette question du raort à la lecture
des jeunes Français de quelle manière
nous pouvons le renforcer je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député et
c'est bien parce que vous aviez un
rapport sur la lecture avec anev que je
vous ai laissé
déborder donc pour le rassemblement
national Roger chudau merci madame la
présidente madame messieur exigant des
savoirs choc des savoirs ces formules
sont d'autant plus creuses qu'elles sont
martiales si j'étais encore professeur
je mettrai dans la marche la copie
ministérielle j'entends bien j'écrirai
travail baclé copie ant quelques
intuitions beaucoup de lacunes et
d'impardonnables oublis les intuitions
c'est le collège unique la fin du
collège unique la les groupes de niveau
matière le redoublement et le DNB
transformé en examen de passage en
seconde tout cela est évidemment
directement tiré du programme de Marine
Le Pen de
2022 c'est un fait vous pouvez le
vérifier sur les documents c'est très
simple donc bravo en progrès mais peut
mieux faire les mathématiques
donc les mathématiques ont été considéré
comme une priorité et je m'interroge sur
la lisibilité de vos priorités mesdames
et messieurs c'est-à-dire que je ne vois
pas pourquoi la
lecture n'est pas la priorité des
priorités quand on sait que 50 % des
élèves de 6e ne lisent encore avec leurs
doigts lorsqu'ils entrent au collège ça
m'a sembléit prioritaire plus que les
mathématiques non pas pour les opposés
mais rien nous empêchait de le faire en
même temps de même rien sur l'histoire
de France bien sûr et rien non plus sur
la géographie de notre beau pays donc ce
sont les lacunes ça quant aux grands
oubliés alors rien sur l'ascenseur
sociale une émission fondamentale de
l'école c'est l'ascenseur sociale bien
rien sur les quartiers prioritaires de
la ville donc 80 % de nos ennuies
Prienne rien sur les rythmes de
calendrier scolaire et encore rien sur
le baccalauréat c'est pourquoi je je
vous ai mis un 5/ 20 et encore enfin je
note sec en général hein bon de quoi
l'exigence des savoirs est-elle le nom
peut-on parler ici sérieusement débauche
d'une politique éducative d'une
reconstruction de l'action éducatrice de
l'État tout observatoire tout
observateur sensé voit bien que tout
cela n'est en fait que la production
htive d'une posture politique et non
d'une politique il s'agit de construire
le récit d'un jeune homme pressé d'un
supposé prodige de la politique à
l'image du fameux Mozard de la finance
qui dirige encore pour quelques temps
nos
destinées bon l'état de délabrement du
système éducatif mérite mieux que des
mesures attives partielles et décousu le
groupe rassemblement national prépare
quant à lui un programme complet de
reconstruction de l'école de la
République à bon entendeur salut merci
pour pour elle et fill Jérôme Legavre
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs mardi 5 décembre le ministre
de l'éducation nationale a présenté les
mesures de son choc des savoirs destiné
à élever le niveau des élèves face à la
banque-route de l'instruction conséquen
directes des politiques destructrices
des gouvernements successifs les remèdes
sont connus rétablir les heures de cours
d'enseignement disciplinaires
massivement supprimés au long des
dernières années réduire le nombre
d'élèves dans toutes les classes tous
les les niveau et donc créer les postes
d'enseignant nécessaires s'agit-il de
cela plus de 3000 postes de professeurs
n'ont pas été pourvus à l'issue des
derniers concours de recrutement et
après tous les postes supprimés depuis
2017 2500 suppressions de postes
d'enseignants sont encore imposés à la
rentrée prochaine il s'agit donc
d'autrees chose plusieurs mesures sont
sont annoncées qu'il est impossible
d'évoquer en 2 minutes prenons l'exemple
des groupes de niveau au collège pour
les enseignements de français et de math
loin de mettre en place des cours de
soutien qui pourraient être apportés aux
élèves en difficulté on décide que tous
les élèves n'auront pas de fait accès à
la même instruction sacré basculement
tout de même outre le fait que la
réduction du volume horaire des autres
disciplines est envisagé ces groupes de
niveau seront flexibles tout au long de
l'année en d'autres termes on transfèt
au collège la logique au cœur de la
réforme du lycée de Blanquer qui a eu
pour conséquence l'explosion du groupe
classe la dstructuration des horaires et
des emplois du temps on s'interroge
d'autant plus que selon le secrétaire
général du SNPD UNSA cette seule mesure
nécessiterait 19000 postes
supplémentaire le ministre n'a budgeté
aucune des mesures annoncées il supprime
des postes comment compte-il s'y prendre
en réalité au nom du fait que moins ça
marche plus on continue il semble bien
que le véritable objectif soit ailleurs
on nous annonce ainsi que le diplôme du
brevet conditionnera l'accès direct au
lycée après avoir supprimé le bac
national le brevet deviendrait un outil
de sélection que vont devenir les élèves
qui ne pourront accéder au lycée
s'agit-il comme le demandait juste après
les annonces ministérielles un sénateur
LR à savoir orienter D
vers l'apprentissage ce sénateur a au
moins le sens de la propos puisqueau
même moment est confirmé l'accélération
du démantellement des lycées
professionnels et de la voie
professionnelle sous statut scolaire
contre la majorité des personnels et des
associations de parents d'élèves merci
monsieur le député pour les républicains
an
jeunevard voilà c'est bon c'est bon
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs très très heureuse de vous
entendre ce matin sur un sujet
évidemment fondamental qui est celui de
cette opération choc des savoirs
exigence des savoirs je crois qu'il y a
un enjeu
fondamental de restaurer le lien de
confiance entre la nation et son école
c'est un enjeu d'avenir majeur alors
évidemment je je reprendrai quelques
éléments de de ce que vous avez dit ce
matin bien sûr l'importance donner au
savoir et j'ai aimé la façon dont vous
avez insisté sur la concentration sur
les acquis je pense que ça c'est une
c'est une inversion de de de de méthode
qui qui est une aversion d'objectif qui
est fondamentale euh importance d'un
socle de culture commune c'est aussi un
point à mes yeux fondamental je voudrais
vous dire que beaucoup des mesures que
vous préconisez rejoignent donnent
raison aux propositions des républicains
que que nous formulons depuis longtemps
notamment l'attention portée aux
méthodes celle qui marche et leur
évaluation lesffit mîre je voudrais dire
aussi que indice de positionnement
social identique les résultats sont
différents ça veut dire que les méthodes
sont fondamentalement
importante redonner du sens aux examens
les groupes de niveau de
remédiation pour redonner confiance en
soi aux élèves tout ça est important
alors j'ai deux questions
euh la première dans un ministère qui
est connu pour être quand même assez
rétif à la réforme j'en parle en
connaissance de cause pour en être issu
comment se passe l'atterrissage de vos
propositions auprès des des professeurs
quel est votre premier retour et la
deuxième question porte sur la formation
des enseignants il me semble qu'il y a
là un champ déterminant à explorer moi
je crois que rien ne se fera sans des
professes
[Musique]
très solidement formé et auquel on aura
donné des exigences précises je vous
remerci merci madame la députée pour les
démocrates Laurent Croisier merci madame
la présidente madame messieurs l'école
et pour le groupe démocrate la première
des batailles c'est l'avenir de nos
enfants l'avenir de notre pays qui se
construit à l'école les annonces du
ministre Gabriel Atal et le lancement de
la mission exigence des savoirs sont
dans la ligne
des propositions des députés démocrates
nous partageons le diagnostic du
ministre oui il y a urgence à élever le
niveau et l'exigence à l'école face à ce
constat il y a ceux qui souhaitent que
rien ne bouge ceux qui à force de
pédagogisme d'oubli des savoirs
fondamentaux et de la culture générale
ont brisé l'ascenseur social et
désespéré les enfants des classes les
plus
défavorisées nous ne réussirons pourtant
aucun des enjeux sans quiéau sans
ambition pour notre jeunesse sans
exigence pour la transmission des
savoirs fondamentaux sans restaurer
l'autorité pédagogique des enseignants
que tous ceux qui pensent que les
professeurs ne travaillent pas assez
sont suffisamment rémunérés ou qu'un
jardin d'enfants peut faire le programme
comme j'ai pu l'entendre ici passe ne
serait-ce qu'une semaine dans une école
maternelle primaire dans un collège ou
un lycée nous n'avons pas seulement une
obligation de moyen mes chers collègues
mais une obligation de réussite et je
souhaite m'arrêter sur le collège il est
parfois décrit comme un tunnel où les
élèves en difficulté ne réparent pas les
lacunes accumulées et où les meilleurs
élèves n'exploitent pas pleinement leur
potentiel nous défendons l'idée d'un
collège modulaire qui n en rien une
remise en cause du collège unique mais
la remise en cause d'un collège trop
uniforme incapable de s'adapter au
profil de chacun des élèves en Suisse
Suède ou au Danemarc les élèves de 6e et
5e sont réparti en groupe de niveau
est-ce que selon vous ce qui est
possible dans les pays du Nord réputé
pour la qualité de leur système éducatif
pour le respect des différences et des
rythmes de chacun est transposable dans
les collèges
français merci monsieur le député pour
les socialistes apparentés Fatia kelashi
oui je tiens tout d'abord à remercier
réellement les auditionnés pour leur
intervention que j'ai écouté le plus
attentivement que je que je le pouvais
et je parlerai d'abord du fond d'abord
la majorité des mesures qui découlent de
cette mission exigence vont à rebours
des faits établis par la recherche en
matière de sciences de l'éducation en
effet dès 2014 le knnesco Poa le
caractère inefficace du redoublement si
le redoublement peut avoir un impact
positif sur les résultats d'élèv des
élèves les plus faibles cet effet n'est
pas très important et il est visible
très souvent que la première année du
redoublement surtout il ne compense pas
l'augmentation de risque de décrochage
scolaire concernant les groupes de
niveau il ne permettent pas aux élèves
les plus en difficulté d'améliorer leurs
résultats scolaires ils permettent aux
bons élèves d'être encore meilleurs bon
c'est formidable mais il condamn les
élèves en difficultés creusement des
écarts de niveau renforcement de la
comparaison sociale réduction du
sentiment d'appartenance à la classe le
calendrier des annonces n'est pas un
hasard bien sûr il ils ont elles ont été
dévoilées ces annonces le même jour que
la publication du classement PISA le
ministre Atal veut donc aussi répondre
au mauvais résultats français pourtant
le classement PISA pointe aussi les
fortes inégalités sociales entre les
élèves un élève un enfant issu d'une
famille défavorisée a en France 10 fois
plus de risque qu'un élève favorisé de
de se retrouver parmi les élèves peu
performants en mathématique par exemple
mais voilà aucune des mesures annoncées
ne s'attaque au problème de fond des
inégalités sociales pire je pense qu'une
partie de ces annonces va les empirer et
puis sur la forme comment mettre en
place les mesures annoncées par le
ministre comment finiss financez-vous
ces mesures comment financez-vous ces
mesures car le PLF 2024 supprime 2700
postes dans le 1emier et le second degré
et la loi de programmation budgétaire
2023-2027 fixe une quasi stab budgétaire
pour l'éducation nationale donc combien
d'enseignants supplémentaires seront
nécessaires pour la mise en place de ces
nouvelles mesur voici ma question
principale merci madame la députée pour
horizon et apparenté agnè
Carel merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général madame
messieurs J'ai été attentive à votre
exposé sur les travaux de cette mission
les constats sont là si le niveau
progresse en primaire depuis 2017 grâce
aux mesures prises sur le dédoublement
les résultats PISA 2022 confirment une
baisse importante du niveau au collège
l'école a besoin comme l'a affirmé le
ministre de remettre l'exigence à tous
les niveaux et une revitalisation
pédagogique à la main des enseignants en
présentant votre travail il a fait des
annonces fortes que nous membres du
groupe horizon et apparenté soutenons il
s'agit de simplifier des programmes avec
des repères annuel indispensable comme
vous l'avez dit de créer un sursaut en
math dès le primaire en adoptant
progressivement la méthode Singapour qui
a fait ses preuves dans de nombreux pays
il propose l'intégration des enseignants
de terrain dans le processus de
labellisation des manuels scolaires
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur les
modalités de cette intégration à quel
niveau vont être leur action il s'agit
également de donner le fin mot aux
enseignants sur le redoublement des des
élèves quand cela est nécessaire c'est
au préalable au préalable pardon des
stages de réussite pendant les vacances
scolaires pourront être exigés
conditionnant le passage en classe
supérieur l'an dernier 40000 professeurs
volontaires les ont animés leur
rémunération serait doublé comme je l'ai
écrit dans le rapport de la mission sur
l'éducation prioritaire le rôle de ces
dispositifs de soutien est fondamental
pour la réussite d'un grand nombre
d'élèves et pour le principe de
l'égalité des chances auxquell je suis
très attaché j'en ajouterai
une quelque chose issue aussi du du
rapport sur l'éducation prioritaire
c'est celui du conventionnement des
cités éducatives avec des orthophonistes
pour plus de dépistage et de suivi cela
me semble indispensable à partir de la
rentrée prochaine 6e et 5e seront
répartis en plusieurs groupes de niveau
flexible en français et mathématiques
les créations de postes permettront de
limiter les groupes d'élèves en
difficulté à une quinzaine la même
organisation sera mise en place pour les
4e 3e dès 2025 je m'en réjouis de de
nouvelles mesures seront prises pour
relever le niveau d'exigence du brevet à
travers plus d'épreuves il faut
réinstaurer l'importance de ce premier
diplôme qui fait nation je ne peux citer
toutes les mesures annoncées vous l'avez
bien expliqué l'objectif général qui
résulte de votre mission est une
mobilisation générale nous ne pouvons
que soutenir ces propositions issu deci
madame la députée pour les écologistes
Francesca Pasquini
oui mesdames messieurs merci pour la
présentation de ces ce travail ce matin
le lancement de la mission destinée à
établir un état des lieux sur l'exigence
des savoirs dont il est question
aujourd' ourdi ne fait pas grand sens
les problèmes de l'école sont déjà
connus depuis longtemps une mission de 8
semaines ne rajoute rien de plus de ce
qui n'a pas déjà été dit par les
syndicats les enseignants et les parents
d'élèves depuis des années cette mission
n'a qu'un seul but tenter de légitimer
la politique du ministre de l'éducation
nationale sa volonté de reformer le
collège est connu de tous et explique la
commande d'une telle mission les
syndicats ont dénoncé un questionnaire à
destination des personnels complètement
biaisé je regrette d'ailleurs de ne pas
avoir trouvé trace écrite de ce de ces
travaux les seuls éléments que l'on
connaît sont les conclusions de la
mission sur la conclusion de la mission
sont d'opaque mesures issu d'arbitrage
présenté par le ministre une large part
de ces mesures reprennent d'ailleurs des
propositions droitières à rebours des
études scientifiques et des demandes des
syndicats d'autres propositions sont
hypocrites et contradictoires avec
l'action du gouvernement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale souite que des
groupes de niveau soient instaurés au
collège et annonce qu'un nouveau schéma
d'emploi sera bientôt dévoilé pourtant
plus de 4000 postes d'enseignants ont
été supprimés dans le projet de loi de
finances 2023 et 2024 ce qu'il faudrait
pour que les enfants apprennent mieux
c'est notamment un enseignant devant
chaque classe des classes avec 20 élèves
maximum au primairire hors des
doublements REP et 25 maximum au collège
madame monsieur je regrette que nous
continuons à dans les fait perdre notre
temps et ainsi perdre des élèves et des
enseignants en route en toute sincérité
je n'ai donc qu'une question pour vous
est-ce qu'en faisant ce travail vous
n'avez pas eu l'impression de brasser de
l'air et de participer à une vaste
opération de communication plutôt que de
répondre aux défis qui agitent l'école
depuis des
années mes chers collègues
ou on laissera mais
mes chers collègues les les orateurs
répondront à toutes les questions et à
toutes les interpellations ensuite mais
là je vais donner la parole au groupe
lotte et Martine
Froget merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs le ministre Gabriel hatal a
annoncé donc le lancement de la mission
exigence des savoirs donc vous avez la
charge qui doit associer l'ensemble des
parties prenantes de l'école du collège
et des lycé
cette annonce fait suite au résultats
des différents classements
internationaux qui confirment tous les
décrochages des élèves français quel que
soit la discipline ou la compétence
observée cet abassement des performances
que rien enen rayille depuis 15 ans doit
nous interroger pourtant les décisions
qui on découlent nous laissent perplexes
si nous sommes d'accord sur l'ambition
visant à élever le niveau global des
élèves la mthode employé et les moyens
dédiés ne ne semblent pas à la hauteur
des enjeux d'abord sur la forme opérer
une réforme significative au pas de
charge pour une application effective
dès la rentrée 2024 et pour le moins
surprenant comment ces auditions menées
dans la précipitation pourraient mener
une vraie réflexion sur notre système
scolaire sur le fond le retour à des
classes de niveau en mathématique et en
français est envisagé certains voilà un
fort risque de réduction du nombre
d'heures pour les disciplines autres que
Cell d'ITE fondamentale et d'un
enseignement davantage standardisé
limitant la liberté
pédagogique de même les syndicats
s'inquiètent de la suppression des
cycles ce qui s'oppose une refonde des
programmes la dégradation des conditions
de travail des enseignants qu'induirit
la mise en œuvre de ces annonces ne
semble pas avoir été pris en compte car
la mise en place des nouveaux programmes
dont il faudrait s'emparer les stages
pendant les vacances à assurer et les
groupes de niveau à organisé vont
incomber aux enseignants déjà en nombre
insuffisant alors que la dernière
réforme n'a pas été évaluée une nouvelle
annoncé une nouvelle est annoncée de
façon précipitée et sans concertation ne
croyez-vous pas que cette dernière
réforme risque d'impacter
défavorablement l'attractivité du métier
déjà fragilisé si l'on en croit les
difficultés à recruter enfin si vouloir
élever le niveau des élèves ne peut être
que partagé centrer les objectifs sur la
refondte des contenus et des
organisations des apprentissages
n'est-ce pas passer complètement
à côté des vrais enjeux et des besoins
de l'école merci madame la députée donc
ça va être à vous mesdames madames et
Messieurs les orateurs pour répondre aux
questions et je vous inv indique qu'il y
a aussi 17 collègues qui ensuite
voudront à nouveau vous poser des
questions donc si jamais vous n'étiez
pas complètement exhaustif dans cette
première partie de réponse sachez que
vous avez
un une deuxième possibilité
ensuite un rattrapage voilà donc je ne
sais pas qui souhaite commencer pour
Monsieur
Geffrey merci beaucoup alors peut-être
quelques éléments de réponse de ce fait
sous contrôle de mes collègues qui bien
sûr s'exprimeront les uns et les autres
euh le premier élément c'est la boussole
qui nous
anime on dédie dans une vie
professionnelle à cette table et comme
nous tous je crois enfin voilà mais
comme tous les professeurs de ce pays à
la réussite de nos
élèves et on ne peut pas se satisfaire
de constater qu'aujourd'hui un élève qui
arrive en difficulté en
6e c'est quasiment à 85 90 % en
probabilité un élève qui sera entr en
difficulté au
brevet on peut pas se satisfaire d'une
situation dans laquelle un élève qui a
du mal à décoder en fin de CP et
quasiment statistiquement enfin un très
grand risque en terme de probabilité de
terminer en très grande difficulté
également au brevet donc nous avons
essayé dans cette effectivement de
proposer un C nombre de mesures qui par
nature sont se discutent par nature
parce qu'on parle de pédagogie on parle
pédagogique et cetera qui se confrontte
aussi à des études scientifiques qui
sont assez nombreuses et sur lesquelles
on s' appuyer mais avec en tout cas
l'impression et en ce qui me concerne je
ne parle que de ma qualité mais
l'impression que j'ai enant que
fonctionnaire de
servir peut-être pas idéalement mais en
tout cas la volonté de
servir alors à partir de là donc par
rapport aux différentes aux différents
éléments qui ont été mentionnés et et
avec évidemment une fois encore tout
tout ce que ça implique en terme de
débat et on a bien conscience que
objectivement je en soit tout se discute
mais je voudrais juste simplement
préciser quelques points le premier
point c'est que il ne s'agit peut-être
pour les groupes de niveau dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure sur eu beaucoup de
questions il ne s'agit certainement pas
de faire en sorte que les élèves les
plus en difficulté apprennent moins
les élèves auront le même programme ils
apprendront la même chose ce sont les
conditions d'apprentissage qui changent
on a souvent l'occasion d'échanger dans
cette enceinte et d'ailleurs je je vous
merci de me faire cet honneur mais sur
les dédoublements par exemple en CP ou
en CE1 on n jamais dit quand on
dédoublait un CP ou un CE1 les élèves
ont difficulté all moins apprendre on a
dit qu'ils allaient mieux apprendre la
même chose c'est exactement la même
chose pour les 6e 5e quand on veut
dédoubler les groupes le constat c'est
que vous avez des élèves qui
aujourd'hui sont j'allais dire en
difficulté et en fait et à forceuie à
l'âge de l'adolescence sont en
souffrance du fait de cette difficulté
se replient sur cette difficulté
n'arrivent pas à en sortir en terme
d'estime de soi sont systématiquement en
C de classe pour les notes et cetera et
cetera est-ce que c'est un service à
leur rendre la réponse est non est-ce
qu'il faut en revanche les enfermer dans
une logique de niveau la réponse est non
aussi c'est pour ça qu'on a écarté
d'ailleurs les classes de niveau dans
nos proposition et c'est pour ça aussi
que nous nous sommes fondés sur un
d'études qui montre que lorsque les
groupes sont une fois encore évolutifs
alors il y a un vrai effet
levier au Portugal par exemple qui est
un pays comme vous le savez connu une
trajectoire très intéressante c'est ces
20 dernières années grosso modo on
considère qu'il faut 10 ans pour
redresser le niveau d'un système
éducatif le Portugal est rentré dans une
trajectoire de ce type là au Portugal
ils ont mis en place des GR de niveau ce
type là sur des matières ciblées le
Portugais les mathématiques et cetera et
avec cettelexib ité des niveaux et ça a
marché on mentionnait tout à l'heure la
Suisse il y a d'autres pays également
nordique qui l'ont fait donc ça
fonctionne dans certaines conditions et
certainement pas en tout cas avec l'idée
de de de réduire le le le volume à
apprendre ça veut dire aussi vous avez
été plusieurs le mentionner qu'il faut
des moyens à mettre en face alors je
suis pas sûr de partager totalement le
le enfin même pas du tout le le
l'évaluation budgétaire qui a été faite
par C organisations que par ailleurs
évidemment je respecte profondément tout
simplement parce qu'il s'agit pas de
dire que pour tout le
monde tout est en effectif réduit des
élèves qui sont très à l'aise en
français ou en mathématique ils ont pas
besoin d'être en effectif réduit en
français ou en mathématique en revanche
des élèves qui sont en difficultés ou
qui ont des fragilités particulières oui
bien sûr cela il faut pouvoir adapter
les effectifs donc il y aura
effectivement un nouveau schéma d'emploi
il y aura pour pour être tout à fait
précis des discussions demain matin en
conseil en conseil
excusez-moi j'ai le nom enfin j'ai l'an
nom CSA voilà en CSA ministériel avec le
ministre et et nous tous sur les les les
sujets de moyens avec les syndical mais
il y aura évidemment des moyens qui
seront associés à cette à cette mesure
donc voilà je je me permets de le de le
redire parce que c'est c'est un point
que vous avez
souligné sur les priorités alors je
laisserai évid les voisin répondre sur
tout ce qui est lecture mathématique et
cetera mais simplement pour dire que euh
dans notre esprit il n'y a pas la
priorité mathématique par rapport aux
autres il y a une priorité savoirs
fondamentaux lire écrire et compter et
les trois évidemment euh vont de paire
lire écrire et compter et donner une
culture
générale dans la loi l'article 1111-1 du
code d'éducation donc vous savez que
c'est un peu votre article frontispice
il est dit que le rôle de l'école c'est
de donner une culture générale cette
culture générale ce mot-là ces termes-là
il n'existe pas dans les programmes il
en a fait une seule mention une fois
dans le programme de cycle 4
aujourd'hui et notre constat ça été de
dire oui ça c'est un enjeu social c'est
un enjeu social parce qu' aujourd'hui on
sait que c'est déterminant dans dans
toute une trajectoire de de vie
professionnelle et cetera et c'est aussi
comme ça que n'est la conscience d'une
destinée
partagée si on parle de fraternité la
fraternité elle passe aussi par une
culture qui est un rapport à l'altérité
qui est un rapport à l'esthétique et
donc du coup quand on quand on quand on
quand on parle de de on a pas repris t
les programmes on va pouvoir y revenir
si vous voulez il y a évidemment cette
dimension culture générale que
mentionnaé tout à
l'heure kine dernier point en ce qui me
concerne parce que je veux pas prendre
trop de temps mais c'est c'est l'enjeu
aussi de finalement par comme ça mais ce
qui marche et ce qui ne marche pas on
voit bien qu'on a différents leviers et
que aucun de ces leviers n'a vocation ni
à être si je puis dire mécanique ni à
être définitif on va activer le levier
du passage au niveau supérieur sous
condition avec des stages de réussite on
va activer ponctuellement et pour
certains niveaux le levier du
redoublement parce qu'il y a des cas où
si si une fois encore vous vous avez des
lacunes trop importantes on y va pas on
va activer le levier des groupes de
niveau et puis on va aussi surtout je pe
d'y revenir activer le levier des
pratiques pédagogiques aujourd'hui quand
vous regardez les résultats au diplôme
national du brevet à IPS identique la
moyenne des élèves peut varier de 10
points terminal donc c'est bien que à
IPS identique c'est à à conditions socio
professionnelles des familles identique
on a des très grande variation liée à la
pratique pédagogique et donc c'est ces
pratiques là évidemment qu'on va
continuer à travailler mais je laisse
mes collègues évidemment détailler tout
cela merci peut-être en complément de de
des réponses d'edoard revenir un petit
peu sur la sur la réception des annonces
donc je reprendrai si vous le voulez
bien un peu mon statut de chef de
l'Inspection générale qui a quand même
beaucoup d'inspecteurs sur le terrain et
qui donc on ont plutôt remonté sous
forme de sonde à ce à ce à ce stade il n
a évidemment rien d'autre que ça plutôt
une réception très favorable de ces
annonces qui dans le fond répondait de
manière assez claire à des constats émis
aussi par les enseignants dans le
questionnaire dont on peut peut-être
s'interroger sur la façon dont il a été
conçu mais pour lequel 230000
enseignants c'est-à-dire près d'un quart
des enseignants ont ont pris le temps de
répondre et c'est donc qu'ils ont
considéré qu'ils pouvaient avoir une
forme de valeur euh je voudrais aussi
revenir sur sur l'engagement qui a été
celui de cette mission aussi bien de
nous quatre que de l'ensemble des
groupes de travail qui ont pendant 8
semaines n'ont pas cessé d'interroger
d'auditionner et de travailler sur une
base de travaux qui existait je ne
reviendrai pas et je pense que Stanislas
reviendra sur les travaux de recherche
mais aussi sur les rapports d'inspection
qui depuis une dizaine d'années font des
constats et des préconisations dont une
partie ont été reprises dans les les
travaux que nous avons mené donc il y
avait une base et une base de travail
qui permettait de d'aller assez vite sur
les constats et de faire émerger dans
l'ensemble des préconisations ou des
recommandations qui avaient été faites
par les chercheurs ou par les
inspecteurs celle qui nous paraissait
construire une vision relativement
systématique un plan d'action
qui permettait de de garder une
cohérence en en de notamment par rapport
à nos objectifs c'est ce c'est ce plan
d'action qui conduit à une forme de
mobilisation et quand je disais que les
enseignants l'avaient plutôt
relativement bien réceptionné c'est
qu'il y avait aussi dans les
propositions qui étaient faites un
certain nombre d'éléments qui
conduisaient à redonner la force de leur
expertise la suppression du dernier mot
au parents la réflexion de l'équipe
autour des moyens de remédiation des
solutions pour étayer le parcours de
l'élève jusqu'au redoublement sont des
éléments qui ont été pris de manière
très positive puisque c'était une
manière de revenir sur le fait que ce
sont eux les professionnels en capacité
de reconnaître les besoins des
professeurs alors bien entendu cela
suppose de la formation euh une
formation très proche du terrain et et
sur le terrain comme elle a déjà été
mise en place depuis 2017- 2018
avec les constellations euh de formation
de professeurs de mathématiques et de
français enfin sur les mathématiques et
sur le français à l'école pour les
professeurs des écoles et ces
constellations ont débordé si je puis
dire sur le collège où à travers les
Labau de math on retrouve aussi cette
formation entrepère qui est beaucoup
demandée avec des conseillers
pédagogiques plus experts mais les les
enseignants sont demandeurs de ces
formations ils travaillent ensemble pour
construire euh leur enseignement euh
donc évidemment cette cette formation
est essentielle euh les et parallèlement
au au aux propositions qui ont été
faites dans ce dans ce rapport il y a
également un travail qui est mené d'une
part par la DGRH sur l' l'attractivité
du métier et ses conditions d'exercice
et plus banalement encore si je puis
dire une note de service de la direction
d'encadrement qui pose le caractère
d'accompagnement pédagogique comme la
fonction essentielle des corps
d'inspection territoriaux premier degré
comme second degré et tout ça participe
à une volonté de formation
d'accompagnant d'accompagnement des des
enseignant qui sera évidemment
nécessaire pour arriver au résultats que
nous souhaiterions voir émerger à la
suite de de ce plan et des mesures qui
ont été prises et juste pour terminer je
dirais à ce sujet que depuis 2014 où le
redoublement a presque totalement
disparu et où il n'y a pas eu de mesure
de soutien des élèves en difficulté nous
n'avons pas vu les résultats progressés
donc de même que nous n'avons pas
d'étude sur le manque d'estime de soi ou
la perte de confiance des élèves qui
passent d'année en année sans réussir je
voilà je je cède la parole à mon
collègue peut-être que c'est c'est ces
études là pourraient être menées aussi
et ferait le pendant des études sur le
redoublement
merci merci beaucoup pour vos questions
je commence par la première ça fait 5
ans peut-être presque 6 maintenant je
crois que je quitte mon laboratoire pour
à peu près la moitié de mon temps pour
me consacrer au Conseil Scientifique
l'éducation nationale alors vous avez
demandé est-ce que j'ai l'impression de
perdre mon temps dans cette mission
également la réponse est non euh par
contre s'il y a de la frustration bien
sûr qu'il y a de la frustration et si
s'il y a un point sur lequel je voudrais
attirer votre attention c'est il y a une
partie de frustration qui est liée au
temps de la prise de décision euh il est
certain que ce serait bénéfique de ne
pas avoir autant de rapidité et plus de
recul sur les prises de décisions ce qui
a marché ce qui ne marche pas d'un point
de vue scientifique il y a évidemment la
frustration aussi sur la prise de
certaines décisions j'ai mentionné les
nuances importantes sur le redoublement
il y a une un autre domaine sur lequel
nous n'avons pas été amenés à discuter
du tout qui est celui du temps scolaire
or il est tout à fait clair qu'il
vaudrait mieux que l'école soit répartie
sur un temps plus important dans la
semaine donc il y a des éléments qui ont
pas été discutés mais les les maires qui
continuent euh contreevance et Maré
d'arriver à ouvrir l'école 5 jours sur 7
doivent être soutenu maintenant euh si
euh je reviens sur les décisions qui ont
été prises moi je suis malgré certaines
frustrations je suis ravi de voir que
progressivement et sur 5 ans je l'ai vu
très clairement les données
scientifiques sont de plus en plus
prises en compte au sein du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et on en a le le
c'est le témoignage aujourd'hui dans ces
dans ces décisions hein sur la la
lecture il n'y a aucun doute qu'il y a
maintenant tout un vocabulaire commun
une série d'études communes qui sont
acceptés par la communauté ce qui était
pas le cas il y a 5 ans je pense que les
choses changent elles changent lentement
parce qu'évidemment elles impliquent la
formation de l'ensemble des personnes et
le débat et c'est ça a été le cas au
cours de cette mission j'en ai aucun
doute là-dessus alors certains d'entre
vous ont mentionné les inégalités les
inégalités sont la cible absolue de nos
réflexions la France a des inégal ité
beaucoup trop importante dans le domaine
de l'éducation la question c'est comment
les réduire il semblerait que les
méthodes pédagogiques le choix des
bonnes méthod pédagogique soit un
paramètre clé pour arriver à adresser
ces inégalités non seulement d'ailleurs
des inégalités sociales mais également
les inégalités de genre pourquoi parce
que quand on a les mauvaises méthodes
pédagogiques et bien souvent ce sont les
familles qui vont compenser c'est là
encore dans le cas de la lecture c'est
tout à fait clair on a ce qu'on appelle
le miracle de Noël qui va se produire
peut-être pour certaines familles
c'est-à-dire que les en fait les les
enfants vont rentrer à la maison et ceux
qui ne savent pas encore lire bah les
certaines familles vont compenser les
grands-parents les parents vont
compenser et l'enfant reviendra de des
vacances de Noël avec un miracle c'est
qui SAA lire en revenant bon ça n'est
pas acceptable pour réduire les
inégalités précisément nous pensons
qu'il faut être capable d'introduire des
méthodes qui marchent et qui ont fait
leur preuve d'un point de vue objectif
scientifique voilà euh alors le point
essentiel je pense de ces mesures c'est
d'apporter plus de soutien aux élèves là
où ils en ont besoin les groupes de
niveau dans ce contexte ne sont pas
forcément une mauvaise chose on aurait
préféré parler de groupe de besoin ça
aurait peut-être été un terme plus
acceptable par tous mais ce que ça veut
dire en pratique c'est marqué quand même
clairement des groupes flexibles
temporaires fixé sur un besoin
particulier des élèves par exemple
l'élève ne connaît pas les fractions
comme on l'a montré dans une note du
conseil scientifique 80 % des élèves
quand ils rentrent en 6e ne comprennent
rien à des fractions les plus simples
possibles et bien là il y a un besoin on
peut intervenir pendant 6 semaines et
l'idée c'est de faire des petits groupes
d'avoir des professeurs qui soient bien
formés à adresser ce point-là d'avoir
aussi une aide peut-être de tuteur euh
intelligent en informatique ça peut être
le cas d'exerciseur et là de répondre à
un besoin précis et ça on sait que ça
marche donc il s'agit pas de dire rien
de ces aucune de ces mesures ne marche
ça n'est pas vrai ce type de groupe de
besoins ça peut fonctionner le tutorat
avec un enseignant qui se consacre à un
élève pendant un temps particulier ça
marche ça on le sait très bien et le
tutor à entre élèves est aussi une
solution qui n'est pas assez explorée et
qui mériterait à mon sens d'être
organisé parce que ça coûte très peu
cher et ça marche très bien et ça
redonne confiance en eux à tous les
élèves voilà parce qu'ils voient qu'ils
peuvent enseigner à un autre élève voilà
et puis je termine sur le point de la
formation vous avez tout à fait raison
que c'est un point absolument essentiel
la formation des enseignants et là
encore il y a d'énormes besoins dans
notre pays ça faisait pas partie de la
demande qui était faite à notre mission
he donc c'est c'est aussi simple que ça
je pense personnellement que la
formation deviend endra de plus en plus
facile à mesure qu'on s'accordera sur
des programmes bien ciblés raccourcis et
des manuels et des méthodes qui
fonctionnent à ce moment-là on saura
beaucoup mieux à quoi former et ce sera
plus facile d'arriver à une meilleure
formation des enseignants mais c'est
clair que il a un besoin considérable et
il faut certainement par rapport à
d'autres pays augmenter la formation des
enseignants
oui je je vais pas être très long parce
que évidemment tout a déjà été dit mais
vraiment pour rebondir sur la nécessité
éidment d'accompagner les enseignants
comme Stanislas l'a dit et ça
ça ça a été dit aussi dans dans dans vos
intervention je l'ai dit aussi en
parlant des labomat en parlant aussi de
l'accompagnement par la recherche alors
peut-être dans un Brouis mais je le
redis à nouveau et c'est vraiment
important et c'est demandé par par les
enseignants et euh je pense que ça ça ça
sera au cœur de de de prochaines
annonces euh on on a jamais dit
évidemment qu'on mettait les maths
devant les autres disciplines et ni que
on nous alliononss supprimer les cycles
ou renier sur d'autres disciplines comme
je dit mais comme je l'ai entendu et
donc ça nous permet aussi de de de
clarifier les choses si çaavait pas été
complètement clair vous nous demandez
comment s'est ressenti sur le terrain
donc évidemment dans les déplacements
j'interroge les uns et les autres et la
première chose que nous entendons
de la part des enseignants c'est que ces
mesures redonnent
confiance aux
enseignants confiance justement dans
leur capacité à évaluer à prononcer ou
pas les les redoublements et puis aussi
le le le le message qui est envoyé c'est
euh il faut travailler pour les élèves
et je je je ce message je peux vous dire
qu'il est entendu depuis quelques jours
que les élèves se disent où la euh il se
passe quelque chose et on doit
travailler alors je voudrais juste
madame la Présidente si vous me
l'accordez vous lire un témoignage
puisque hier j'étais dans donc en
visite donc c'est un dispositif élan
c'est à bourge qui accueil des élèves
exclus temporairement des établissements
donc des élèves en grande difficulté qui
sont possiblement les futur décrocheurs
et première interpellation on me dit ou
là là nous nos enseignants nous ont dit
Monsieur le Recteur maintenant qu'il
allait falloir travailler parce que à la
fin il y a le brevet si on n pas le
brevet euh ça va mal se passer pour nous
donc je peux vous dire que le message
est très bien passé et alors j'aurais
dit est-ce que vous avez entendu parler
de la prépa seconde ils en avaient
entendu parler Jeuris demandé alors
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ils ont
commencé à parler jeurais dit demain je
vois les
députés un représentant de la nation
vous avez qu'à écrire une lettre et leur
dire ce que vous en pensez donc des
élèves grand décrocheur
euh mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous sommes des élèves ayant participé
au dispositif élan de bourge qui
accueille des élèves exclus
temporairement des établissements suite
à la rencontre avec Monsieur le Recteur
de l'Académie sur la prépa seconde nous
avons réfléchi sur l'apport que pourrait
avoir cette année scolaire auprès de
tous les élèves je me permets de résumer
un peu cela leur offrirait une année
supplémentaire pour acquérir toutes les
compétences suffisantes pour rentrer au
lycée afin d'obtenir le baccalauréat et
de pouvoir poursuivre leurs études s'ils
le souhaitent il peut-être intéressant
de prévoir des sessions de stage afin
qu'ils puissent découvrir différents
métiers et trouver leur projet
professionnel merci d'avoir écouter
notre lettre et c'est signé entre autres
Timéo et mathtis des élèves en très
grande difficulté et je peux vous
assurer que personne ne l'aura tenu la
plume merci merci pour pour cette
première partie des de réponses et nous
allons continuer maintenant avec de
nouvelles questions donc nous commençons
avec Virginie lanlot pour une minute
madame la Présidente merci mesdames
messieurs il est une question qui a été
largement reprise et rebattu dans les
médias depuis les annonces de du
ministre c'est celle du retour du
redoublement permettez-moi d' l'aborder
sous un angle légèrement différent de
celui sous lequel elle a fait la une de
l'actualité car il me semble que
l'essentiel de cette mesure est ailleurs
l'essentiel pour moi est dans le fait
qu'elle remet enfin l'enseignant au
centre le professionnel de l'éducation
c'est lui c'est lui qui sait ce qui est
bon ou non pour ses élèves et c'est
c'est lui qui doit avoir et qui aura
donc désormais la charge de décider la
pertinence ou non de les faire redoubler
par cette par cette mesure le ministère
n'a pas tant je crois relancer les
redoublements que replacer les
professeurs dans leur rôle de sachant de
prescripteur c'est à eux de
diagnostiquer de prescrire en matière
d'éducation à l'instar des médecins en
matière de santé à l' star des médecins
à eux aussi d'écouter l'enfant pour
produire leur diagnostic de partager
avec les parents leurs réflexion et
d'expliquer le sens de ce qu'il
presrivent chacun sa responsabilité
chacun son rôle celui de premiers
instructeurs pour les enseignants celui
de premiers éducateurs pour les parents
notre école souvre souffre depuis
plusieurs années d'une confusion de ces
rôles voilà ma conviction aussi ma
question est-elle simple au-delà du
redoublement quelles autres mesures
sont-elles à l'étude par le ministère
pour les clarifier merci la députée
grzelia m Melkor pardon pour une minute
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs je vous remercie pour vos
engagements respectifs mais également
collectifs ici dans le cadre de la
mission exigence des savoirs que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse vous a confié cette mission
avait pour objectif de lui proposer des
pistes de solution pour renforcer le
niveau des élèves dans les savoirs les
plus fondamentaux le français et les
mathématiques je me réjouis bien sûr des
annonces que le ministre a fait l'une
d'entre elles qui concer concerne le
recours à l'intelligence artificielle a
été cependant peu évoqué et pourtant
elle me semble très intéressante en
effet les outils numériques peuvent se
révéler utiles notamment pour simplifier
certaines tâches des professeurs et pour
favoriser la différenciation pédagogique
ce sont aussi des leviers de soutien
scolaire efficace dans le cadre de
devoir à la maison ou ou sur table
toutefois il est évidemment nécessaire
de penser le recours à l'intelligence
artificielle à l'école de manière
raisonnée aussi pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quel regard vous portez sur
cette question et nous donner quelques
exemples concrets de son utilité je vous
remercie merci madame la députée Sarah
Legrin messieurs dames puisqu'il est
beaucoup questions ici de mathématique
j'aimerais vous soumettre et notamment à
vous Monsieur le Directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire un problème de
mathématique que je ne parviens pas à
résoudre je vous lis l'énoncer le petit
Gabriel veut mettre en place des groupes
de niveau au collège il a calculé qu'il
lui fallait 4000 professeurs
supplémentaires le Syndicat national des
person personnel de direction de
l'éducation nationale lui en calculant
de façon à ce qu'aucun groupe ne dépasse
40 élèves trouve 2300 postes par niveau
et par discipline ce qui fait 19000 en
tout question numéro 1 selon quel calcul
le petit Gabriel est-il arrivé à 4000
postes seulement question numéro 2
sachant que le même petit Gabriel a
supprimé dans le dernier budget 480
postes de 2 degré sachant que du fait
des démissions record et d'une
désaffection pour ce métier si difficile
et si dévalorisé 1850 postes n'ont pas
été pourvus dans le second degré dont
200 50 en mathématique et 242 en lettres
en vertu de quel théorème encore non
découvert le petit Gabriel compte-il
donner quelques réalités à ses annonce
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
Alexandre
portier merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais déjà vous remercier pour le
travail que vous avez réalisé dans le
cadre du choc des savoirs le ministre a
annoncé une réécriture des programmes
scolaires sujet sur lequel je voulais
revenir parce que dans un pays qui a
déjà les programmes scolaires parmi les
plus chargés au monde c'est évidemment
toujours avec prudence que que l'on
accueille ce type d'annonce
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît d'abord
nous indiquer qui va avoir la charge de
s'occuper de cette réécriture des
programmes est-ce je vais être un peu
provocateur mais volontairement est-ce
aux services qui depuis des années ont
chargé les programmes et les ont
transformé en PAV éisible que l'on va à
nouveau demander maintenant de les
réduire c'est un exercice un peu
schizophrénique mais surtout et c'est le
plus important pourriez-vous s'il vous
plaît nous dire quels sont les objectifs
de cette de cette réécriture parce que
pendant que l'on parle exence des
savoirs le Conseil supérieur des
programmes où j'ai le plaisir de siéger
lui planche sur l'éducation à la
sexualité et l'éducation au
développement durable donc je
m'interroge vraiment sur la cohérence la
sincérité des annonces qui sont fait euh
des moyens qu'on veut y allouer et
surtout très concrètement qu' allez-vous
supprimer dans les programmes pour faire
la place nécessaire à l'apprentissage
des fondamentaux parce que quand on
ouvre le code de l'éducation on reste
quand même assez dubitatif on trouve
deux pages de propositions il a
peut-être un moment donné falloir
arrêter cette folie et faire vraiment le
ménage merci merci monsieur le député
Anne bruniera
oui merci madame la Présidente et tout
d'abord mesdames et messieurs je tiens à
saluer votre travail dans le cadre de
cette mission qui a permis à Gabriel
Atal de faire des annonces fortes pour
élever le niveau des élèves français
parmi ces annonces bien sûr la mesure
qui vise à redonner sa valeur au Diplôme
National du Brevet et à s'assurer que
les collégiens disposent effectivement
des connaissances nécessaires à la bonne
poursuite de leur scolarité au lycée je
veux parler ici des prépa lycé nous
devons collectivement réaffirmer cette
objectif d'accompagner les élèves vers
le lycée qu'il soit professionnel
technologique ou général et j'ai deux
questions à ce sujet tout d'abord qu'en
sera-t-il des modalités logistiques des
modalités pratiques de cette prépa lycée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
détails sur ce point et deuxièmement je
voulais réaffirmer ici que c'est un
devoir de l'éducation nationale que
d'accompagner les élèves notamment ceux
qui en ont bien sûr le plus besoin ceux
qui sont le plus en difficulté mais
aussi y compris au-delà de leur 16 an
limite de scolarité obligatoire en
France car nous avons voté dans la loi
école de la confiance cet accompagnement
envers les 161 et je ne peux m'empêcher
de faire le lien avec ce point merci
merci madame la députée Estelle Fest
oui merci madame la Présidente et merci
mesdames et messieurs de venir parmi
nous ce matin pour nous faire part de
vos travaux de très haut niveau d'une
part et de bon sens presque d'autre part
ma question porte sur les savoirs
fondamentaux et le niveau d'exigence ce
qu'on peut avoir au regard du niveau de
nos élèves et de certains candidats au
professeurat des écoles même en français
on sait que ce qui stigmatise réellement
les élèves c'est de ne pas pouvoir
devenir des citoyens pleins et entiers
et de s'insérer également
professionnellement parce que le niveau
de français est très fragile je pense
notamment à la gramère l'orthographe et
la conjugaison on sait également que les
juris sont préoccupés tous les ans par
le niveau des candidats au concours de
professorat des écoles je me souviens de
l'exemple du terme chancelan qui avait
été interprété comme un terme relevant
de la chance par les candidats au
concours l'an dernier je crois qu' il
est légitime qu'on s'en préoccupe et
donc j'aimerais savoir comment vous vous
comptez peut-être vous emparer de ce
sujet notamment pour nos collégiens
puisque je crois que le ministre
Blanquer avait pas mal remis les les
choses au carré à la à l'école mais au
collège on ne fait plus de dicté plus de
conjugaison très peu de rédaction voilà
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
cine
Calvez
merci madame la Présidente euh merci à
vous d'avoir relevé à plusieurs reprises
le fait de prêter attention aux
inégalités de genre vous l'avez dit il
faut pouvoir compter et adapter les
pédagogies adopter adapter aussi les
moyens je voulais vous poser des
question plus largement sur le lien
entre le choc de savoir et les
compétences transversales savoir
mémoriser s'organiser débattre décrypter
c'est important comment concilier les
deux on peut et vous l'avez dit faire
place à l'empathie l'altérité le
tutorant re élève me paraît être à
souligner également et je voulais
également vous poser une question sur la
place des associations au côté de la
communauté éducative pour relever
ensemble le choc des savoirs comment
aménager aussi bien la confiance des
enseignants que ces partenariats avec
les associations il me paraît important
de pouvoir préciser quelles sont les
marges de manœuvre dans le cadre de ce
formidable enjeu collectif merci merci
madame la députée Léo
Valter Monsieur le Directeur Général
monsieur de le 5 décembre le ministre
annoncé sa volonté de labéliser
l'émanuel scolaire du premier degré dont
l'efficacité des contenus a été prouvée
par la science cette annonce suscite en
moi comme chez nombre d'enseignants
plusieurs interrogations qu'entend
exactement le ministre par efficacité
prouvée par la science existe-t-il une
évaluation de l'ensemble des manuels
scolaires du premier degré si oui est-il
possible de la consulter quels ont été
ou quels seront les critères retenus qui
composera la commission chargée de cette
labellisation qu'adeviendra-t-il des
manuels non labellisés qui prendra en
charge h cpce1 le surcout induit par
leur remplacement que se passera-t-il
enfin si un enseignant décide malgré
tout d'utiliser un manuel non labellisé
ou de s'en passer comme ils sont
nombreux à le faire souvent avec brio
question subsidiaire le manuel lego ou
néo pas copie sans les jolies images de
la méthode bcher de nos grands-parents
premier manuel à avoir été conçu par le
ministère expérimenté en 2020 par
Jean-Michel blaner a-t-il été évalué et
obtiendra-t-il le label je vous remercie
de votre écoute et de vos réponses merci
monsieur le député Emmanuel
Antoine merci madame la Présidente la
récente publication des résultats de
l'enquête PISA 2022 l'illustre de façon
clair et nette le niveau de nos élèves
en mathématiques baisse de façon
inquiétante
ensuite pardon ensuite de la remise du
rapport vilanite aurossian le plan
mathématique a été é lancé en 2018 il
visait à la mise en œuvre des 21 mesures
préconisées par le rapport et devait
permettre de relever le niveau en
mathématique des jeunes français pour
autant les résultats de l'étude PISA
2022 ne semblent pas indiquer de
résultats approbants certes les
résultats du plan mathématique ne
pourront s'observer que dans la durée
vous l'avez dit mais pour autant ne ne
peut-on pas commencer à en évaluer
l'efficacité car 5 ans après son
lancement aucun progrès tangible ne
semble visible
merci madame la députée Philippe
Berta merci madame la Présidente
l'affaiblissement du niveau des élèves
en mathématiques mais aussi en Scien et
je tiens cette distinction atteint la
côte d'alerte classements internationaux
la multiplicité des tribunes sur le
sujet ou même certains rapports
parlementaires ne semblent conduire à
aucun effet et pourtant c'est par
exemple de Scien environnemental
biologie chimie physique dont il s'agit
bref des matières qui forment le socle
de notre avenir et la richesse de notre
pays ainsi en science les élv en
français en fin de CM1 figurent
désormais en avant-dernière position des
pays de l'OCDE seul le Chili demeurant
derrière nous pas mieux en fin de 4è où
seul 3 % des enfants sont au niveau
avancé en science alors qu'ils sont en
moyenne 10 % dans les pays de l'Union
européenne ou de l'OCDE on retrouve
cette catastrophe dans le seement
supérieur où tous mes collègues peuvent
témoigner des lacunes des étudiants en
premier cycle ou dans nos classes
préparatoires certaines peines désoréis
à recruter comment espérer former des
citoyens acteurs dans un monde dominé
par les sciences et les techniques des
citoyens éclairés aptes à réagir à
l'offre extrémiste et autiste pour
exemple 47 % d'entre eux refusent encore
d'accepter le réchauffement climatique
un sur 4 REM en cause de la TER de
l'évolution un sur 6 atteste d'une terre
plate alors que nous savons que la
plastic neuronal est majeure jusqu'à
l'adolescence mais que nos enfants ne
sont amenés à côtoyer dans ces années
quasiment que des enseignants Isus de
filières littérair n'est-il pas temps de
plaider pour une stratégie d'urgence
permettant un accès organisé à travers
nos plus de 1700 structures dédiées à
une culture scientifique technique
industrielle et sanitaire des plus
essentiels je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député
u merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs je prends la parole au nom de
mon collègue Christophe Marion qui étant
malade vous prie de l'excuser pour son
absence mais pr bien soin de vous
écouter bien sûr à distance monsieur
Marion souhaiterit vous interroger sur
l'une des mesures de votre mission que
votre mission a proposé la création de
groupe de niveau flexible à compé de la
rentrée
et en
français Monsieur le Recteur Gilles
Albou il semblerait que vous ayez déjà
expérimenté cette organisation à Mayotte
pourriez-vous dès lors nous en adresser
un retour d'expérience précis en effet
cette annonce du ministre de l'éducation
nationale inquiète certains se demandent
comment pourrait-il y avoir assez de
professeurs pour réaliser cette mission
tandis que d'autres s'interrogent sur
l'efficacité même de ces groupes de
niveau alors que ma n'est pas
particulièrement connu pour attirer
manif massivement pardon les enseignants
comment avez-vous fait pour mettre en
place ces groupes de travail renforcé
qui s'élevait à 6 he d'enseignement par
semaine dans le cadre de votre plan dire
lire écrire quand on pensz les
enseignants et quels effets avez-vous pu
constater sur la réussite des élèves
qu'en est-il par ailleurs de la fin
prévue pour ces groupes de niveau on
entend qu'ils seront flexibles mais que
ceux-ci sont envisagés pour toute la
durée du collège ces groupes n'ont-ils
pas vocation au contraire à réintégrer
les élèves le plus rapidement possible
dans une classe plus homogène Christophe
Marion et moi vous remercion merci
monsieur le
député Stéphane Lenormand
oui merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs écoutez après 35 ans dans dans
l'éducation nationale ce que j'ai
entendu ce matin pour moi c'est un peu
un remake c'est un Star Wars saison 10
ou 11 j'espère que votre mission va
atterrir et débouchera sur des
propositions concrètes qui releveront le
défi que l'on partage tous je voudrais
simplement attirer un peu dans le
prolongement de ce qu'a dit le collègue
sur la situation des outremes dans votre
approche par rapport justement à cette
recherche d'amélioration du niveau
général sachez quand même que dans les
outremires nous avons la même
problématique que dans l'Hexagone mais
qui sont amplifié par de nombreux
phénomènes qui sont naturellement liés à
l'insularité à l'éloignement mais qui
sont aussi liés à des structures
sociales différent à des manques
d'équipement à des immensités de
territoire et je ne parle pas de la
formation des enseignants et la
formation continue où souvent ça se
résume par une petite inspection tous
les 3 ou 4 ans et c'est pas forcément
l'accompagnement qu'il faut pour aider
les enseignants dans cette lourde
mission merci merci monsieur le député
Stéphane
Mazar merci madame la Présidente ma
question porte sur le sujet particulier
des lycées agricoles actuellement pour
pouvoir intégrer un lycée agricole il
faut que l'élève propose une candidature
spécifique et exigeante via Affelnet
sans jugement de valeur on sait juste
que la formation spécifique offerte en
lycée agricole est assez éloigné des
disciplines validées par le DNB tel
qu'il est conçu actuellement aussi
est-ce que l'acceptation d'un cette
filière très spécifique sera aussi
soumise à l'obtention du DNB comme pour
l'entrée en seconde générale classique
et si oui et en cas d'échec au DNB
est-ce que les candidats au lycées
agricole seront intégrés aux fameuses
classes prépa lycée
merci merci monsieur le député Géraldine
Banier madame messieurs dans le cadre du
groupe d'étude économie du livre et du
papier nous recevions il y a 15 jour une
calligraphe meilleur ouvrier de France
cela a été l'occasion de réfléchir à une
évolution souvent peu évooqué de notre
société moderne voilà plus de 50 ans
qu'on apprend plus les Liers et des
Liers que l'écriture n'est plus un geste
central dans l'apprentissage en découle
nécessairement des conséquences
attention adresse minutie du geste
manuel structuration de la pensée
s'apprennent différemment il arrive
qu'on fasse directement passer au
clavier des enfants pour qui le geste
d'écriture est un peu difficile la trace
écrite de nos ancêtres sera bientôt
numérique et on y perd sans doute un peu
des personnalités qui s'expriment quelle
est votre réflexion sur l'évolution
intervenu et à venir quelle place pour
l'écriture dans l'exigence des
savoirs merci madame la députée Frédéric
Meier merci madame la Présidente afin de
mener à bien cette mission exigence des
savoir Gabriel hatal a souhaité lancer
une consultation de tous les professeurs
via un questionnaire qui leur a été
adressé malheureusement de nombreux
personnels de l'enseignement ont été
oubliés lors de cet envoi ce
questionnaire a été vivement critiqué
par les enseignants le jugeant comme une
insulte à leur intelligence des
questions beaucoup trop orientées de
nombreux sujets pas abordés notamment le
nombre d'élèves par classe puisque les
classes français sont les plus chargés
d'Europe alors quel est votre avis sur
ce questionnaire avez-vous un retour
pensez-vous que ce retour est biaisé
compte tenu du fait qu'il ne concerne
pas tous les enseignants et quel vous
avec vous avez-vous comme regard sur ce
résultat je vous remercie merci madame
la députée violette
spbou merci madame la Présidente dans ma
circonscription à mouveau près de Lille
j'ai échangé avec l'équipe de direction
et les enseignants du collège ver qui
mène beaucoup d'actions pour l'égalité
des chances le socle des connaissances
et la citoyenneté suite aux annonces de
Gabriel Atal notre ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous préparez une
réforme d'ampleur du système éducatif
français centrée sur l'urgence nationale
du niveau des élèves parmi ces annonce
vous l'avez dit il y a la mise en place
de groupe de niveau au collège dès la
rentrée 2024 en math et en français les
enseignants ils sont bien entendu très
favorable en 6e comme en 5e math plus
français c'est environ 9h par semaine
par par classe à multiplier donc par
deux ou trois pour faire ces groupes de
niveau pour les classes de 6e il y en a
trois à mouveau par exemple il faut au
minimum une personne un enseignant en
plus quels seront donc les moyens prévus
pour ces groupes moyens supplémentaires
notifiés au rectorat ou moyens constant
heure poste ou heure supplémentair je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
Emmanuel
Pellerin merci madame la présidente
madame messieurs face aux récentes
évolutions du système éducatif français
qui inclut l'implémentation de nouveaux
programmes scolaires de la maternelle au
collège l'introduction de Manuel
labellisé la restructuration des classes
en groupe de niveau et les modifications
apportées au brevet je m'interroge sur
les méthodes d'évaluation de ces
réformes ma préoccupation principale
concerne l'amélioration des compétences
fondamentales des élèves teles que
l'orthographe la grammaire et le calcul
tout en veillant à maintenir un
équilibre entre les exigences
académiques et le bien-être des élèves
ma question est la suivante comment le
ministère prévoit-il d'évaluer et
d'assurer l'efficacité de ces mesures
sur le niveau global des élèves en
prenant en compte à la fois les
performances académiques et le bien-être
des élèves merci infiniment merci
monsieur le député Sophie
met merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs cela fait 2 mois que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse Gabriel Atal a lancé la
mission exigence et savoir en assurant
sa coordination vous avez recueilli les
résultats des concertations portant à la
fois sur l'enseignement primaire le
collège et les lycées c'est en tant
qu'élu d'une circonscription
majoritairement rural que j'aimerais
vous interroger le retour de terrain se
voulait massif et quatre thématiques
étaient abordées notamment les pratiques
et les organisation pédagogique en la
matière vous avez reçu des témoignages
de professeurs de zones rurales en
tirez-vous des spécificités que nous
devons prendre en compte dans le choc
des savoirs que nous appelons de nos
vœux et de manière plus générale dans
les les futures législations ou même
réglementation si tel est le cas quelle
est votre analyse je vous remercie merci
madame la
députée Sylvie
bet merci madame la Présidente madamees
messieurs les orateurs merci pour les
précision que vous venez de nous
apporter l'annonce du choc des savoirs
et les mises en œuvre dès la rentrée
2024 laisse craindre le risque d'une
éème réforme dans l'urgence qui
déstabiliserait encore plus un système
déjà très fragilisé j'aurais de
questions la méthode de Singapour a été
validée pour l'apprentissage des
mathématiques le retour à la méthode
syllabique pour la lecture est-il prévu
la question du travail personnel des des
élèves semble être encore un tabou de
nombreux parents pens que les devoirs à
la maison sont interdits alors que nous
l'avons tous vécu ici ce sont les
exercices faits après la classe qui nous
ont permis d'encrer les apprentissages
pensez-vous qu'une évolution des
pratiques est possible merci
merci madame la députée Fabien di
Philippo bien merci madame la Présidente
merci aux différents intervenants les
grands esprits se rencontrent
effectivement je compter sur le premier
point aborder l'interdiction des devoirs
écrits en tout cas après la la classe et
ce travail hortant scolaire il me semble
indispensable comme elle l'a dit pour
consolider les savoirs alors n'est pas
question ici de renforcer des inégalité
parce que les milieux sociaux sont
aujourd'hui familiiaux sont aujourd'hui
très hétérogènes mais et d'avoir un
niveau global qui augmente de nouveau et
des savoirs qui soient fondamentaux qui
soient mieux consolidés et puis la
deuxième question qui concerne l'obésité
elle peut paraître assez éloignée du
sujet mais en 4 ans chez les moins de 18
ans elle a été multipliée par 4
aujourd'hui à l'école on consacre 30
minutes théoriquement d'activité
physique ou en tout cas de mouvement par
par jour est-ce que vous pensez pas que
c'est ces ces activitéslà qui peuvent
être chronophages avec le temps de
préparer les activités de se changer de
sortir de la classe et bien elle devrait
se faire hors champ scolaire avec des
associations ou se faire avec l' avec
l'intervention de personnel extérieur
qualifié diplômé d'dites
associations merci monsieur le député
madames et messieurs c'est à vous pour
répondre à ces nombreuses questions mais
qui pour certaines se recoupent donc je
laisse la parole déjà à Monsieur Geffry
et puis on reprend d'accord Mons gfy
merci beaucoup alors je je vais
reprendre simplement quelques points euh
parce que on va on va se partager les
choses peut-être d'abord sur le
questionnaire parce que vous avez été
plusieurs à mentionner le fait qu'il
aurit éventuellement été biaisé alors
d'abord ce questionnaire il a été en
grande partie élaboré par nos soins et
comme toujours quand vous posez des
questions si vous voulez qu'un maximum
de gens répondent vous êtes obligé de
poser des questions qui sont en nombre
limité on aurait bien aimé poser 60
questions mais si vous posez 60
questions vous êtes sûr que les gens ne
prennent pas le temps de répondre donc
il faut trouver l'équilibre entre un
nombre suffisamment éclairant et en même
temps suffisamment faisable pour pas
prendre gens trop de temps bon premier
élément deuxième élément on a posé des
questions qui étai pour l'instant
d'entrée assez ouverte puisque les les
les professeurs pouvaient choisir telle
ou telle réponse priorisé et cetera et
cetera vous avez 81,2 % des professeurs
qui se disent favorable ou très
favorable à la mise en place de groupe
de besoin au collège quand on interroge
les professeurs du premier degré sur le
redoublement est-il suffisamment
préconisé aujourd'hui pour les élèves
grandes difficulté scolaire 69,7 % vous
disent que non 23,6 % vous disent que
oui mais certains élèves doivent
recevoir unent personnalisé pour passer
en classe supérieur et 6,7 % vous
répondent que oui il y a pas de question
biaisée c'est juste est-ce que vous
pensez que il est suffisamment enfin oui
non ou oui mais il devrait y avoir des
aménagements supplémentaires euh vous
avez des questions sur la remise en
cause de l'autorité par exemple ou 48,3
% des des répondants ressentent une
remise en cause de leur autorité de la
part de la société
donc quand on les interroge sur la
culture générale ils sont 67,9 % à
préconiser d'identifier des
connaissances incontournables de culture
générale qui pourrait être commune à
tous leurs élèves et C et c'est c'est
dans le c'est public hein c'est c'est
voilà donc je je ne pense pas que soit
biaisé en revanche ce qui est
intéressant c'est que sur inst de sujet
ça montre une
une on va dire une très forte majorité
de
professeurs qui pense la même chose et
on est quand même sur 230000 répondants
je rappelle pour 800 quelques 1000
professeurs euh d'une part et d'autre
part ça montre aussi que sur certains
sujets comme celui que vous avez évoqué
des devoirs écrits à la maison euh les
constats sont plus partagés sur ces
sujets-là on est sur sur un équilibre et
on voit bien que ça ça fait vraiment dé
bats euh dans dans le premier degré on
est grosso modo sur à peu près 50 50
donc voilà ce questionnaire c'est une
base parmi d'autres il y a eu énormément
d' auditions il y eu aussi beaucoup de
gens qui nous envoyé des contributions y
compris très spontanées euh parfois
d'ailleurs assez vigoureuses mais c'est
très bien et et on a
évidemment systématiquement tout lu et
et essayer de prendre en compte le le le
meilleur le mieux possible c'est c'estes
remarques donc ça c'est en TER de
méthode sur le fond alors il y a il y a
un nombre de questions qui ont été
posées donc je j'en prends quelquesunes
qui me concernent très directement sur
les effets du plan mathématique je
rappelle simplement que les élèves qui
sont
euh qui ont qui ont passé les résultat
de PISA puisque vous avez posé la
question de PISA PISA donc c'est Pisa
2022 donc ce sont des élèves qui étaient
en seconde en 2022 donc qui sont rentrés
au collège en 2017 très
concrètement donc ces élèves-là n'ont
pas bénéficié du plan mathématique
puisque le plan mathématique est un ni
du plan français d'ailleurs le plan
français plan mathématique sont des
plans qui ont trouvé à s'appliquer
jusqu'à présent dans le premier degré et
on est actuellement à peu près 60 % des
professeurs du premier degré qui ont
bénéficié du plan français 60 % des
professeurs qui ont bénficié du plan
mathématiqu et on continue sur cette
cadence pour que comme on s'était fixé
d'ailleurs dès le départ dans 2 ans tous
les professeurs des écoles on bénéficié
ce qui est intéressant c'est que et et
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il y a des
fruits on a deux comment dire
thermomètres qui nous donnent des
résultats sur les mathématiques on a nos
propres évaluations national d'abord qui
montre une amélioration constante depuis
3 ans des résultats en mathématiqu en 6e
et plus importante en éducation
prioritaire que hors éducation
prioritaire le deuxème élément c'est que
on a l'enquête pears l'enquête PES une
enquête interationale qui a été faite
sur les CM1 comme vous le savez donc
c'est pareil c'est pearls 2022 donc ce
sont les élèves qui qui qui était qui
était en CM1 en 2022 de mémoire 2021 et
qui eux pour le coup ont bénéficié alors
quasiment pas du dédoublement puisque
ils étaient déjà trop tard mais en
revanche assez nettement du plan
mathématique et qu'est-ce qu'on observe
c'est que la France est le seul pays
dans l'enquête pearls le seul pays
européen dont le niveau des élèves a
progressé
entre 2016 et 2021 le
seul tous les autres pays ont Conn ont
connu une chute de résultat on aurait dû
logiquement connaître une chute de nos
résultats parce qu'il y avait eu la
situation covid or non seulement pas et
alors après ça on aurait pu se dire il y
a une chute plus ou moins importante
selon la durée de fermeture des écoles
alors non seulement on n pas connu une
chute mais on a connu une progression
d'où le fait que on peut se permettre
d'être optimiste sur un certain nombre
d'éléments de trajectoire dans le
premier degré qui sont objectivement
réels dernier élément qui est important
c'est que nous arrivons maintenant à un
stade où on est capable de de comment
dire de voir finalement un peu les
résultat des évaluations y compris par
circonscription et donc de regarder si
une circonscription au plan mathématique
et plan français ont été
particulièrement développé on a un effet
sur le niveau en mathématique et en
français des élèves et la réponse est
oui donc oui il y a des résultats mais
effectivement vous avez raison ils sont
centrés sur le premier degré parce que
le plan mathématique et français ont été
centrés sur sur le premier degré euh
troème élément vous avez été plusieurs
enfin entre ces questions là et les
précédentes he parce queon avait dit
qu'on qu'on se permettrait de compléter
si on avait pas tout dit a évoqué la
question de l'autorité des
enseignants et la façon finalement de de
consolider cette
autorité d'abord cette autorité elle
repose sur l'antériorité du savoir le
professeur il sait ce que l'élève ne
sait pas encore et c'est pas parce qu'on
a un smartphone dans sa poche et qu'on
peut aller voir très rapidement la
réponse à une question sait ou qu'on est
capable
d'analyser et deuxème chose l'enseignant
il a une compétence non seulement de
transmission mais d'évaluation des acqu
de ses élèves or il y a deux mesures
comme vous savez qui sont effectivement
extrêmement importantes la première
c'est le fait que c'est
effectivement le corps professoral qui
décide des
préconisation pour le passage en classe
supérieure ou de l'éventuel redoublement
le deuxième élément c'est que comme vous
le savez
également le ministre a annoncé une
mesure qu'on avait proposé la fin des
correctifs académiques et d'ailleurs des
consignes
académiques on va dire dégradant les
consignes nationales à l'examen du
diplôme national du brevet autrement dit
c'est le professeur qui s'est noté c'est
le professeur qui note et c'est la note
du professeur qui a retenu plusidment la
note des professeurs qui est retenu
puisque par définition au sein des juris
de professeurs ils continueront à
harmoniser mais il n'y aura plus de
correctif académique et ce sont des
éléments qui évidemment participe
fortement à restaurer l'autorité des
professeurs le troisième élément que
vous avez mentionner sur je voudrais
revenir c'est et et Caroline Pascale
évidemment il sera sera plus long que
moi mais c'est sur les programmes et la
place de
l'écrit euh alors il y a il y a un
constat qui complètement partagé au sein
de l'émission On on l'a dit tout à
l'heure
c'est un qui a des objectifs annuels à
l'UR des
programmes de que ces programmes soi
conçus aour de ce que doit apprendre
l'élève y compris pour être lisible
vis-à-vis des familles aujourd'hui on
doit avoir les programes les plus épais
d'Europe je dis d'Europe parce que je je
veux pas m'aventurer au-delà sur le CDE
mais je serais pas surpris qu'on a les
PRAM plus ép de le
CDE ces programmes honnêtement quand
vous êtes parents d'élèves pour
comprendre ce que votre enfant doit
savoir à la fin de l'année il faut quand
même y passer un certain temps bon donc
l'idée c'est que on revienne sur des
choses qui soi beaucoup plus
recentré mais constru autour de ce que
doit apprendre l'élève en terme
d'objectif annuel ou avec quoi il a été
en contact parce que on sait bien aussi
qu'il une progression et avec cette
logique de de clause de revoyure à la
fin des ces on fait pas disparaître cl à
l'intérieur de ces programmes très
clairement nous nous souhaitons nous
avons préconisé nous souhaitons que la
place de l'écrit soit profondément
redynamisé à tous les niveaux de la
scolarité parce que si on lit sans
écrire au bout d'un moment on sait plus
lire et que la formulation d'une pensée
complexe et l'acquisition et la
diversification vocabulaire elle passe
par la lecture et par l'écriture et
c'est un enjeu d'égalité des chances dès
le départ donc très clairement ce sera
au cœur des programmes qui vont trouver
à s'appliquer ces programmes seront
élaborés j'allais dire selon les
garanties habituelles au sens où ils
seront
effectivement proposés par le Conseil
super des programmes qui comme vous le
savez des garanties d'indépendance en
vertu de la Loi et euh et ensuite soumis
à concertation publié et cetera je
rappelle également que ces programmes
ils seront révisés progressivement par
tranche maternel CP CE1 CE2 pour cette
rentrée la rentrée 2024 CM1 CM2 6e pour
la rentrée
2025 5e 4e 3e pour la rentrée 2026
euh sur euh les vous avez posé la
question des spécificités du rural
sur le rural alors on a eu en fait dans
les 230000 réponses au questionnaires il
y avait également 230000 il y avait deux
questions qui étaient complètement
ouvertes c'est champ libre où les où les
personnels pouvaient répondre ce qu'il
voulaient donc évidemment ça c'est un
peu plus long à traiter parce que vous
avez par conséquent 560000 réponses avec
500 caractères à chaque fois donc c'est
un peu c'est un peu plus corias on va
dire il y a deux choses qui ressortent
quand même assez clairement et et et pas
seulement dans ce questionnaire mais de
manière générale quand on parle de de la
ruralité en terme de
besoins il y a tout ce qui tourne autour
de l'accès à la
culture qui est évidemment un point pour
nous important et vous savez notamment
que dans le cadre du du passculture
c'est c'est un élément qui est
évidemment fondamental c'est rendre
accessible notamment pour des élèves qui
sont scolarisés dans le isoler un
certain nombre de de de de biens ou
d'offres culturels et le deuxième sujet
qui est très récurrent qui n'est pas un
sujet de savoirs fondamentaux mais qui
touche à l'ambition des élèves c'est les
questions d'orientation de découverte
des métiers
avec la même question d'ailleurs
c'est-à-dire rendre possible et
faciliter la découverte des métiers de
secteurs différents de spécialités
différentes et cetera et cetera et donc
alors c'est c'est pas forcément l'objet
de l'audition d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
l'un des enjeux de la découverte des
métiers qu'on est en train de de mettre
en place par ailleurs euh voilà et avec
ça normalement je pense avoir tout dit
en ce qui me concerne mais c'est-à-dire
que très partiellement répondu à vos
questions oui je vais essayer de de
compléter un peu sur les programmes
j'irai très vite parce que Édouard a
déjà dit beaucoup de choses je je
reprendrai hein ce que ce que nous avons
évoqué c'est-à-dire le fait vraiment de
renverser la logique et la philosophie
de l'écriture des programmes de manière
en effet à ce qu'il soi beaucoup plus
lisible par les familles même si c'est
souvent un vœux pieux mais là on va
essayer de le réaliser et qu'il soit
tourné véritablement vers ce que les
élèves doivent savoir à la fin de
l'année d'enseignement qui est la
l'heure et non pas peut-être se faire un
peu plaisir avec tout tout ce que les
professeurs aimeraient euh enseigner
donc ça c'est c'est le premier axe et
c'est un axe important ils seront comme
ils l'ont toujours comme ils le sont
toujours écrits à la fois par des
professionnels de de terrain encore en
classe si je puis dire et puis par des
inspecteurs territoriaux et généraux qui
je le rappelle sont souvent dans les
classes même s'ils ne sont plus en dans
la dans la fonction d'enseignant euh la
la la question de de la rédaction de ces
programme et je ne voudrais pas faire
une pirouette mais je pense que le temps
rapide dans lequel ils vont devoir être
réécrit et presque un point positif et
que la la la la simplicité la clarté et
d'une certaine manière l'efficacité de
ces programmes doit être en partie lié
aussi au fait que nous allons devoir
aller vite et décider rapidement je
pense que c'est aussi le cas pour le
socle pour avoir été dans l'écriture du
précédent et qui avait duré des mois
mois et des mois et des mois plus on
avançait plus on en mettait donc je
crois que là le fait d'avoir à aller
vite d'avoir à trancher et d'avoir
finalement décidé très de manière très
synthétique de ce que nous devrons
mettre dedans est plutôt un atout la
deuxième chose peut-être un point sur la
la pratique de l'écrit qui a déjà été
évoqué par Édouard vous avez peut-être
eu connaissance du rapport que
l'Inspection Générale a écrit sur la
pratique de l'écriture notamment cm qui
a montré exactement les constats que
vous avez partager avec nous qui sont
ceux d'une absence de pratique de
l'écrit euh donc les recommandations
sont désormais très fortes des des des
des propositions faites par l'Inspection
générale et partagé avec la dgsco
devrait arriver dans les classes avec
presque une charte de l'écriture euh
qu'est-ce que chaque enseignant doit
faire chaque jour de manière à ce que
l'élève pratique l'écriture de manière
comme Édouard l'a souligner à ce que la
combinaison écriture et lecture soit
beaucoup plus associée et ce dès la
Matern on a peu évoqué la maternelle ce
matin il y a un plan déjà en cours les
programmes seront revus et toutes les
question de calligraphie que vous avez
posé madame sont au cœur de ce plan
maternel c'est-à-dire véritablement la
pratique par l'élève de du dessin qui
conduit à l'écriture donc ces éléments
là sont pris en compte et pas simplement
dans la mission exigence des savoir
c'est peut-être pour ça que nous l'avons
pas évoqué là mais déjà en amont par les
politiques que nous avons commencé à
mettre en place deux autres sujets si
vous voulez bien et puis je laisse tout
de suite la parole la prépaonde euh que
vous avez également évoqué pour en dire
de mots peut-être déjà pédagogique euh
la cette prépa à vocation à se
construire autour de trois axes un
premier qui est conforter l'acquisition
ou plutôt d'ailleurs corriger
l'acquisition des fondamentaux qui n'ont
pas été acquis puisque le DNB n'a pas
été validé se préparer à la suite donc
c'est vraiment une préparation au lycée
euh donc et c'est bien la vocation de
cette classe et puis le troisème axe
c'est de redonner confiance à ces élèves
aussi bien parce qu'ils maîtrisent mieux
les acquis qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à
construire et parce qu'ils se préparent
mieux à la suite de leur de leurs études
ça veut dire sans doute et nous sommes
encore en train d'y réfléchir un premier
semestre construit sur la la la la
l'appui sur ce qui n'a pas été encore
euh acquis notamment en terme de
fondamentaux mais aussi en terme de
confiance avec un suivi individualisé
fort de ces élèves de manière à ce que
toute difficulté soit immédiatement
repérée et accompagné et un deuxième
semestre qui commence à orienter vers la
seconde qui sera celle choisie par
l'élève et à laquelle il pourra ensuite
accéder ça veut dire là aussi découverte
en effet peut-être des métiers quelques
possibilités de classe avec des secondes
découverte des plateaux technique pour
ceux qui iront en en lycée pro donc une
approche de la seconde qu'ils
connaîtront ensuite enfin sur
l'évaluation je voudrais pas être trop
longue euh cette évaluation elle va de
des mesures et et de leur efficacité
elle doit être en effet pensé dès la
mise en place de ces mesures et nous
sommes tous les cas très alignés sur
cette question ça veut dire que du côté
de la DEP et nous avons déjà travaillé
avec Douard avec magda Tomasini pour que
se prépare un suivi de cohorte qui
permettent d'envisager de manière très
individualisée bien sûr sur
échantillonnage les effet de ces mesures
les évaluations nationales exhaustives
seront aussi pour nous des indicateurs
forts de la prise en compte et de de du
progrès qui sera celui de nos élèves et
enfin la présence sur le terrain encore
une fois des inspecteurs est aussi en
manière peut-être d'évaluation plus
qualitative de de de vérifier la
l'efficacité de ces
mesures merci Monsieur Deen je vais
tenter d'aborder quelquesunes de vos
excellente question c'est pas facile et
en tant que scientifique j'aimerais
avoir du recul et consulter aussi
d'autres collègues mais je vais tenter
donc d'abord sur les programme de
mathématique et la possible difficulté
d'arriver à les réformer on n peut-être
pas d'accord sur le l'urgence parce que
c'est vraiment pas facile de faire un
bon programme je souhaite très vivement
personnellement que l'on regarde
attentivement ce qui se passe à
l'étranger parce que le cerveau des
enfants est le même partout et pour
l'apprentissage des mathématiques on a
parlé de la méthode de Singapour il y a
une organisation extraordinairement
rationnel et efficace de l'apprentissage
des mathématiques au primaires et il
faut absolument qu'on regarde comment
c'est fait comment c'est organisé qu'on
prenne ce temps et que ce soit intégré
dans les programmes français j'espère
qu'on qu'on y arrivera mais c'est
vraiment le but d'arriver à des
mathématiques qui soit plus concrète qui
soit aussi appuyé sur des outils imagés
des outils mentaux dont on connaît
l'efficacité par exemple l'idée qu'un
nombre c'est comme une barre c'est une
clé de de la méthode de Singapour la
ligne numérique et cetera dans ce
domaine l'examen en fin de première va
jouer un rôle très important et là aussi
je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
sortir des sentiers battus à ne pas
faire un examen comme d'habitude avec
des maths très abstraites mais au
contraire l'idée c'était le mot de
Caroline Pascale d'avoir un examen de
math appliqué qui soit applicable en
sciences applicable dans tous les
domaines qui porent donc sur
l'interprétation des graphes sur
l'interprétation des probabilités qui
soit aussi peut-être plus attraayant
pour les élèves parce que il porte sur
des vrais problèmes et pas sur des
choses extrêmement abstraites donc là il
y a un vrai enjeu aussi d'arriver à
trouver des équipes he qui qui répondent
à ces questions là voilà euh sur les
manuels je réponds brièvement l'idée de
la labellisation des manuels c'est
vraiment d'aider les enseignants et
l'ensemble du système c'est pas de les
contraints donc la liberté pédagogique
est inscrite et reste et il s'agit pas
donc d'obliger à choisir tel ou tel
émanuel mais il s'agit de s'appuyer sur
les données qui existent et qui sont
réelles sur l'efficacité de tel ou telle
méthode et parfois oui de tel manuel pas
toujours donc par exemple sur néo je
sera g rond répondre mais le manuel est
trop récent pour qu'on ait du recul du
point de vue statistique sur les manuels
de quoi on dispose on dispose d'études
internationale sur l'efficacité de telle
stratégie elles sont toutes très
convergentes et convergentes aussi avec
des statistiques françaises par exemple
sur la lecture c'est vraiment les
données sur la lecture sont extrêmement
claires et tout ça avait été dit
d'ailleurs par l'Observatoire national
de la lecture depuis 20 ans donc c'est
pas ça n'a fait que ce
consolidé il y a la nécessité d'inclure
rapidement des correspondances graphem
phonem un R très rapide deux fois deux
fois par semaine minimum deux par
semaine et tout le monde est d'accord
là-dessus on ne parle pas d'ailleurs de
méthode s laabig puisque le mot a été
évoqué mais on parle de méthode phonique
ou
graphophonologique et bien sûr ça n'est
pas absolument pas opposé à la
compréhension le donc il y a un texte du
conseil scientifiqueel je renvoie
là-dessus décodage et compréhension vont
main dans la main il y a juste une étape
très importante 6 mois de focalisation
sur apprendre le code du français et
ensuite on peut comprendre ce qu'on lit
voilà voilà donc là il s'agit simplement
d'apporter une aide comme on l'a fait
depuis le départ en en attirant
l'attention sur ces données
scientifiques et maintenant en attirant
l'attention sur le fait qu'il y a des
manuels qui respectent mieux ou pas que
d'autres ces ces résultats scientifiques
la place de l'écriture est centrale on
le sait d'ailleurs par des études
scientifiques elle est indispensable au
départ parce que ça aide à apprendre à
lire d'avoir un geste d'écriture ensuite
il faudrait pas qu'on se focalise trop
sur ce geste d'écriture par un outil
comme on dit dans l'éducation nationale
l'outil scripteur n'est-ce pas un stylo
ou un crayon euh je regrette
personnellement que l'éducation
nationale soit pas capable d'apprendre à
tous les élèves à taper correctement sur
avec un clavier avec tous ses doigts
parce que c'est extrêmement efficace il
y a des méthodes pour cela euh il est
important de penser aux enfants avec
dyspraxie qui sont quand même assez
nombreux et qui risquent d'être bloqués
dans leur scolarité si on insiste sans
cesse sur le stylo donc voilà il faut
être flexible dans ce domaine mais on
peut écrire bien entendu avec un clavier
le la création de texte la compréhension
de ce qu'on écrit le vocabulaire sont
les points centraux de ce point de vue-
làà on a parlé un moment brièvement de
du retour à la dicté je retrouve plus
dans mes notes évidemment mais oui c'est
le savoir fondamentaux et le niveau
regrettable de de maîtrise du français
l'obsession pour l'orthographe et pour
la dictée est une obsession française
qui n'est pas le cas dans beaucoup
d'autres pays elle est à notre sens
exagéré on en parlait encore hier au
conseil scientifique il doit être
possible d'insister sur le vocabulaire
sur la compréhension plus que sur la
dicté qui un exercice assez stérile euh
et la simplification de l'orthographe
devrait être aussi réexaminer puisqu'on
arrive même pas à appliquer ce qui a été
proposé en
1990 et et et accepté en 1990 donc là il
y a quand même des pistes pour se
centrer à nouveau sur l'essentiel et la
dicté je suis heureux de le dire même si
c'est une sorte de réflexe dans
l'éducation nationale de revenir à la
dictée ça n'est pas du tout un travail
essentiel à notre point de vue euh quoi
d'autre sur l'A sur lia c'est très
intéressant et tu vas en parler
certainement Gill il y a là des pistes
extrêmement intéressante et je suis très
content qu'avec cette mission on soit
aller au-delà du réflexe que j'ai
entendu plusieurs fois qui était liya ça
va simplement être des élèves qui
trichent avec avec l'intelligence
artificielle c'est ça va évidemment bien
au-delà de ça ça va révolutionner
l'éducation ça commence à le faire avec
la possibilité d'avoir des exercicesurs
pour chaque élève et le fait que chaque
élève soit personnalisé mis au travail
est extrêmement important du point de
vue de l'apprentissage parce que ça veut
dire un retour sur erreur très efficace
c'est évidemment très difficile pour un
enseignant de donner un retour à chaque
élève à chaque instant ce que peut faire
l'intelligence artificielle et dans le
domaine de l'accessibilité et notamment
de l'accessibilité pour l'apprentissage
des langues c'est très intéressant
d'avoir des euh soit des machines avec
qui on peut converser dans une langue
étrangère soit simplement la mise en
connexion avec un locuteur natif et on a
parlé de ça dans le domaine de la
mission j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse le
mettre mettre en place peut-être sous
forme d'expérimentation que des classes
qui sont isolées rurales par exemple
puissent avoir un locuteur natif à
condition qu'il y a un outil extrêmement
efficace qui permett de de de connecter
la classe avec un locuteur natif à
distance ça se fait dans certains pays
on a parlé de l'Uruguay en particulier
qui est entièrement équiper en
informatique extrêmement transparente
pour l'éducation il faudrait peut-être y
penser dans notre pays aussi de pas
seulement de s'équiper mais d'avoir des
outils très fluide et d'adopter
l'approche qui a été celle de de
l'Uruguay et puis je termine sur les
l'évaluation
pour le conseil scientifique deéducation
nationale c'est un point clé et on est
effectivement très bien doté en France
avec la DEP un outil statistique pour
surveiller comme le l'IT sur le feu
année après année les progrès des élèves
malheureusement évaluer une politique
c'est plus compliqué que ça évaluer une
politique ça voudrait dire pouvoir
comparer des élèves qui ont ou qui n'ont
pas fait l'objet d'un d'un changement
voilà or lorsqu'on change la totalité
d'un pays en même temps ça n'est pas
possible donc il faut peut-être avoir
une réflexion un petit peu plus
distancier vis-à-vis de ça accepter que
par exemple une cororte d'élèves
commence tout de suite et la cororte
l'autre cororte commence l'année
suivante ce qui permettrait d'étudier
les effets des décisions politiques
sinon on risque de d'avoir des variables
confondues et c'est très difficile à ce
moment d'évaluer l'effet de telle ou
telle politique je termine en disant
simplement que la France s dotée d'un
bel outil de ce point de vue là qui
s'appelle idée idé ee qui est un outil
de sciences social dirigé par Marc
gurgan et Adrien pavli sous l'in dester
du flot vous connaissez le prix Nobel
d'économie pour justement aider à
évaluer les politiques en matière
d'éducation randomiser mesurer savoir
comment mesurer tout ça demande une
organisation scientifique qui n'est pas
négligeable là il y a il y a vraiment
beaucoup d'attention parce que je crains
qu'on ne soit pas tout à fait en mesure
d'évaluer toutes les décisions qui ont
été prises
là alors tout a pratiquement été été dit
donc je vais essayer de de de de
rebondir sur sur quelques points qui de
demande de précision d'abord évidemment
les sciences merci pour pour la question
alors j'en avais parlé évidemment en
propos introductif hein parce que
évidemment dans la culture générale dans
ce qui nous anime il y a bien évidemment
la culture scientifique et et même on va
dire en amont de la culture scientifique
le raisonnement appuyé sur les sur les
faits scientifiques et l'esprit critique
comme on l'a dit donc ça doit faire
évidemment partie du socle euh on on l'a
dit on l'a écrit et ce sera évidemment
dans dans dans ce qui va animer la
rédaction des programmes et évidemment
d'où l'intérêt aussi de de de cette
épreuve en première en fin de première
qui doit qui doit tirer tout ceci hein
avec
évidemment la vérification l'acquisition
des des objets mathématiques et
Stanislas l'a dit dans leur manipulation
mais aussi eu dans la la manière
d'appréhender les problèmes et aussi la
manière manière de de de construire un
un raisonnement logique de lire un texte
et de lire un texte scientifique et et
donc de de de vérifier cette cette
culture scientifique commune ça se
travaille évidemment pas uniquement sur
l'année de première ça doit se
travailler sur sur tout un cursus ça
veut dire évidemment qu'il faut
travailler en amont sur la formation des
enseignants et la diversité de du
recrutement donc nous on n'a pas
travailler sur sur le recrutement et la
formation initiale on a fait quelques
propositions par contre sur sur sur la
formation continue Caroline et et
Édouard on en
parlait et il y aura on va dire une
suite à à ce
travail notamment de de autour des des
labos mathématiques puisqu'on en parle
et qui doivent s'étendre autour des IREM
et qui deviennent des ires ça doit vous
vous vous faire plaisir monsieur le
député puisque voilà au-delà des maths
on on parle de science euh
et et aussi puisque ça a été évoquer je
le redis euh l'accueil dans nos
établissements d'associations qui
doivent venir faire de la médiation
scientifique alors j'ai cité la main à
la patte parce que évidemment notre
collègue Étienne GISS que nous avons
auditionné et en est le porteur mais
aussi de matin jein qui est porté
notamment par les les collègues de de la
société mathématique de de France et et
d'autres très très belles expériences
euh sur sur lia quelques quelques
témoignages il a évidemment c'est aussi
un outil
d'apprentissage en autonomie alors moi
je je j'ai pu assister à des très très
belles démonstrations euh notamment sur
Matha sur la Lilo et et sur Yota qui
sont
aujourd'hui en phase d'expérimentation
dans les dans les écoles euh
évidemment des des des des outils sont
en développement je voudrais revenir
aussi sur l'intelligence artificielle
générative tu tu en parlais tout à
l'heure et et vous montrer aussi enfin
témoigner de de belles expériences que
que que nous menons que nous menons dans
l'académie mais qui se mène aussi en
France avec là
aussi vous prenez un groupe en grande
difficulté et d'abord vous vous le
familiarisez à l'intelligence
artificielle alors évidemment on a des
des des outils qui qui qui sont
adaptés des élèves euh qui peuvent être
des élèves en situation de handicap ou
des élèves décrocheurs et vous leur
faites euh construire un compte alors
vous allez me dire ah oua alors là ça
veut dire que ils vont ne plus apprendre
à à écrire et donc l'intelligence
artificielle générative va sur la base
de certains mots
clés rédiger un compte alor je j'ai pu
assister je je témoigne he de de de de
l'intérêt suscité par les élèves de voir
finalement à partir de quelques mots
clés ce qui était écrit et de découvrir
ainsi de redécouvrir le goût de la
lecture et d'aller vérifier finalement
dans ce qui a été écrit si ça
correspondait bien à ce qu'ils avaient
eux-mêmes en tête donc il y a aussi
cette interaction de finalement entre
l'élève le le le le le but que qu'on
s'était fixé de comparer ce but à ce que
l'intelligence artificielle finalement a
sorti et ça amène là aussi à travailler
sur l'esprit critique et ça réconcilie
aussi un certain nombre d'élèves avec
lesc cure et des élèves qui de fait
après rebondissent vont écrire leur le
leur propres compte donc voilà on vit
avec l'intelligence artificielle et il
faut familiariser les les les élèves
avec cet outil et c'est un outil qui
peut permettre aussi beaucoup beaucoup
de déblocage et puisque je parle
d'expérimentation Stanislas l'a dit on
est on est tous les tous les quatre
persuadé que évidemment la tout toutes
nos préconisations se basent sur à la
fois les l'expérimentation mais derrière
l'évaluation de ces expérimentations et
la formation de ceux qui qui vont qui
vont les appliquer et ça me permet de
rebondir sur les questions qui ont été
posées sur l'outrmer qui est évidemment
avec la ruralité il y a beaucoup de
points communs de fait entre l'outremè
et la
ruralité un magnifique champ
d'expérimentation alors j'ai la chance
d'avoir une belle expérience en outremè
et puis maintenant dans un territoire où
il y a beaucoup de ruralité et où on
peut mener de de de belles
expérimentation et donc puisque vous
m'avez interrogé sur le plan dire lire
et écrire d'abord dire parce que il se
dit beaucoup de choses que évidemment
euh on va pas imposer
néo à tous les écoliers de France ou
Navar et d'ailleurs on l'a pas imposé
alors néo c'est le manuel que nous avons
euh choisi collectivement à Mayotte pour
la pour pour les CP nous les nous
l'avons acheté nous l'avons acheté pour
tous les élèves parce que les élèves
n'avaient souvent pas de manuel
voilà et donc ça a été notre première
volonté d'équiper les élèves de Manuel
d'avoir un livre et d'avoir un livre sur
lequel on pouvait suivre et ce manuel on
l'a choisi avec les inspecteurs on l'a
chisi aussi avec les conseils de
l'inspection générale je tiens à le dire
on a été fortement accompagné et
évidemment et je le dis aussi les
équipes qui avaient l'habitude de
travailler sur un manuel et évidemment
qui en était satisfait ont continuait à
travailler avec ce manuel et on n' pas
un pososer un manuel à des équipes qui
nen voulit pas et par contre le le fait
d'avoir choisi un manuel et de l'avoir
choisi tous ensemble ça nous a permis
aussi plus efficacement d'accompagner
des collègues parce qu'on a et vous le
disiez en nreem des collègues qui sont
souvent en difficulté alors pourquoi
plus qu'ailleurs parce qu'on a beaucoup
plus de contractuels qu'ailleurs VO
puisque vous le disiez on a aussi du mal
à recruter malheureusement c'est aussi
ce qui arrive sur des territoires un peu
reculés et ce qui nous permet de de
accompagner les collègues sur le plan
dire lesécrire euh il y avait
évidemment le le le le dispositif il y
avait à peu près 6 dispositifs il y a le
dispositif 100 % lecture en CP vous me
demandiez euh les résultats ce qu'on a
pu voir euh sur l'évolution après
justement ces dispositifs et Édouard le
disait hein il y a pas que évidemment ce
qu'on a fait nous-même il y a aussi ce
qui a été engagé au niveau de la de la
dgsco avec le plan mat le plan français
mais euh et l'accompagnement de
l'inspection générale et euh en 2 ans on
est passé en lecture de un on va dire la
moitié des élèves qui arrivaient à lire
à la en CE1 à maintenant 2/3 en 2 ans à
moitié 2/3 et à CP 1/3 d'élèves qui
étaient on va dire à l'aise sur les
automatismes des déchiffrages à
maintenant la moitié là aussi en 2 ans
1/3 la moitié voilà et sur le collège
vous vous nous interrogez beaucoup sur
les groupes les groupes de niveau je
voudrais revenir là-dessus parce que
évidemment puisque vous nous interroger
sur les groupes qu'on a appelé les
groupes petit lecteurs petit scripteur
et les groupes de besoins quand on a mis
et quand on a expérimenter ça aussi à
Mayotte un de une de nos motivations
c'était aussi de
réconcilier les parents avec
l'école et et je le dis parce que on a
beaucoup parlé ici de mixité la mixité
sociale et la mixité scolaire elle ne
s'impose pas et que au bout d'un moment
quand les les parents ont l'impression
que leurs enfants vont être attirés et
tirés vers le bas dans une dans la
classe parce que il y a trop d'élèves en
difficulté en fait ils vont mettre leurs
enfants ailleurs et quand on est à
Mayotte ils vont les envoyer en
métropole y compris si quand ça ça coûte
très très cher aux familles et avec
tout toute la peine de de l'éloignement
donc il faut réconcilier réconcilier
alors j'entends hein que évidemment ça
va profiter peut-être aux bons élèves
mais déjà ça les sécurise et ça c'est
important et
puis vous nous parlez des moyens mettre
en place des des des des groupes de
niveau ça permet aussi et c'est toute la
politique de de l'égalité des chances
qui est mené à partir évidemment des des
doublements de CP CE et grandes sections
c'est aussi que les moyens qui vont être
mis sur sur ces groupes il soit orienté
vers ceux qui on ont le plus besoin
c'est ce qui vous a été présenté
c'est-à-dire des groupes à plus petits
effectifs pour les élèves qui sont en
plus grande difficulté et des groupes on
va dire à taille normale pour les élèves
qui ont qui n'ont pas de de difficulté
pour suivre c'est ça que nous avons fait
ça génère pas çaengendre pas
automatiquement plus de moyens surtout
dans un territoire où il y a déjà
beaucoup de d'élèves en difficulté par
contre ça demande une organisation ça ça
demande un travail à priori ça demande
un travail de formation des élèves et
c'est là-dessus évidemment que qu'on on
est en train de réfléchir et qu'on a
fait un certain nombre de préconisation
et qu'on va accompagner évidemment les
équipes pour mettre en place ces
dispositifs à partir de la rentrée
prochaine fort des quelques expériences
qui ont été
menées merci beaucoup oui monsieur Deen
vous pouvez tout à fait rajouter quelque
chose excusez-moi de de prendre encore
un peu de votre temps mais il y a un
point très important qui a été souligné
par Gilles et sur lequel je voulais
attirer l'attention c'est vous avez
poser des questions sur l'attractivité
du métier d'enseignant et euh c'est vrai
que c'est un très gros problème
puisqu'il y a des postes qui ne sont pas
remplis euh c'est vraiment une question
fondamental qui n'était pas posé à la
mission euh il est évident que le
salaire joue un peu euh ou même beaucoup
que les conditions de travail jouent
beaucoup mais il y a un point qui est
quand même essentiel et je crois que
Gill l'a abordé c'est les le sentiment
d'efficacité personnelle mon expérience
pour avoir travaillé avec des
enseignants dans le casadre de de
diffusion de méthode de lecture
expérimentale avec le laboratoire c'est
la même que ce que tu as dit avec le
manuel néo c'estàd que quand on donne
aux enseignants une bonne méthode qui
fonctionne bien ils se sentent beaucoup
mieux ils sont parfois septique au
départ pour participer à une
expérimentation et au bout d'un an quand
il voi des résultats auprès de leurs
élèves et notamment des élèves
défavorisés ça change tout et donc je
pense que ce sentiment d'efficacité
personnelle si on arrive à le restaurer
par le biais de certaines des mesures
qui sont proposées ben on rés en partie
le problème de l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant en tout cas de la fuite de
certains enseignants qui qui n'en
peuvent plus oui merci beaucoup et moi
je voulais ajouter un complément quand
même et rappeler que dans le Conseil
supérieur des programmes nous avions
trois parlementaires enfin trois députés
puisqu'il y a cinq parlementaires qui
siègent et je rappelle le nom de nos
trois députés c'est Madame Fatia
kelwashi monsieur Christophe marionan et
monsieur Alexandre portier voilà donc
qui euh je n'en doute pas seront très
vigilants et attentifs et nous ferons
des retours réguliers je l'espère de de
cela en tout cas moi je tiens vraiment à
vous remercier pour la la qualité des
échange et le les réponses que vous avez
pu nous apporter en en cette fin d'année
sur cette mission exence des savoirs et
je dis à mes collègues que nous pourrons
poursuivre nos échanges sur ce sujet dès
la rentrée puisque nous entendrons
monsieur Gabriel àal dès notre première
réunion de 2024 le mardi 16 janvier
voilà et donc je vous souhaite à toutes
et à tous une excellente fin de journée